ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 4
vereinbarte debatte zu dem thema
suizidhilfe liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen unter diesem tagesordnungspunkt
wollen wir im rahmen einer orientierungs
debatte das thema suizidhilfe erörtern
im februar 2020 hatte das
bundesverfassungsgericht das vom
bundestag im jahr 2015 beschlossene
verbot der geschäftsmäßigen förderung
der selbsttötung aufgehoben und ein
umfassendes recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben erkannt heute wollen wir offen
auch über fraktionsgrenzen hinweg über
mögliche neuregelungen diskutieren um
vielen abgeordneten die möglichkeit zu
geben sich an der debatte zu beteiligen
haben sich die fraktionen verständigt
dass insgesamt 38 abgeordnete aus allen
fraktionen für jeweils drei minuten das
wort erhalten
insgesamt ist eine redezeit von 114
minuten vorgesehen alle anderen
abgeordneten können ihre redebeiträge zu
protokoll geben
die parlamentarischen geschäftsführer
haben sich ferner darauf verständigt
dass es keine codes intervention und
keine zwischenfragen geben soll
ich bitte nun tatsächlich die plätze
einzunehmen wenn sie an dieser debatte
teilhaben wollen und dem thema
entsprechend die notwendige
aufmerksamkeit hier herzustellen
ich eröffne die aussprache das wort hat
der kollege ansgar heveling aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion ansgar heveling gehört
auch zu den abgeordneten die eine
fraktionsübergreifende lösung hier
vorschlagen zur assistierten suizid
hilfe
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen unser grundgesetz ist die
freiheitlichste verfassung die unser
land je hatte
es garantiert jedem einzelnen einen
immensen freiheits raum und verliert
zudem verleiht dem einzelnen vielfache
rechte diese freiheit auch durchzusetzen
daher respektieren verfassungs und
rechtsordnung sogar die entscheidung des
einzelnen über das eigene leben zu
verfügen und dem eigenen leben ein ende
zu setzen auch mit fremder hilfe
aber unser grundgesetz ist auch eine
werteordnung die väter und mütter des
grundgesetzes haben mehr geschaffen als
eine lose sammlung subjektiver rechte
des einzelnen mehr geschaffen als einen
baukasten zur durchsetzung individueller
rechte gegen andere oder gegen den staat
so steht zu beginn unseres grundgesetzes
mit artikel 1 die klare aussage und der
klare auftrag die würde des menschen ist
unantastbar
das ist gleichermaßen die eröffnung
eines freiheits raumes für den einzelnen
wie seine begrenzung im interesse
ethisch moralischer grundkonstante und
so durchzieht selbst ohne das ist eine
besondere nennung bedürfte die bejagung
des lebens von artikel 1 ausgehend
unsere verfassung im umgang mit der
beihilfe zur selbsttötung zeigt sich das
gesamte spannungsfeld der ganze wieder
streit zwischen dem freiheitsdrang und
seiner legitimen grenze ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass unsere
verfassung solche grenzen zieht dort wo
es um die autonome entscheidung des
einzelnen geht muss dessen autonomie
geschützt werden geschützt werden
vor beeinflussung dieser autonomie durch
dritte denn nur wo sie sich
unbeeinflusst entfalten kann bedeutet
autonomie tatsächlich selbstbestimmung
ich halte es daher für richtig die
geschäftsmäßige beihilfe zur
selbsttötung grundsätzlich unter strafe
zu belassen so wie der bundestag ist
schon im jahr 2015 beschlossen hatte das
bundesverfassungsgericht lässt diesen
weg auch nach seiner entscheidung vom
februar 2020 ausdrücklich offen
es ist nun aufgabe des gesetzgebers nur
dort eine rechtfertigung zuzulassen wo
die tatsächliche autonomie der
entscheidung des einzelnen auch wirklich
zuverlässig festgestellt werden kann
die ambivalenz eines suizid wunsches ist
wissenschaftlich erwiesen
hier muss der gesetzgeber seinem schutz
auftrag nachkommen denn eine einmal
getroffene entscheidung ist irreversibel
die sorgfalt muss daher besonders groß
sein das kann nur durch ernsthaften und
umfassende beratungen ethische
beratungen auch im sinne von
alternativen zum sterbewunsch
gewährleistet werden
am ende bleibt unsere verfassung ist ein
grundgesetz für das leben und nicht für
das sterben und das muss ich in der
gesamten rechtsordnung widerspiegeln
vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege ebeling
nächster redner seine kollegin beatrix
von storch der ausstoss von storch ist
die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der afg fraktion im
bundestag
herr präsident meine damen und herren
wir führen heute eine debatte über
suizidhilfe gegensatz zur sterbehilfe
geht es also nicht nur um schwer kranke
sondern um alle suizidwilligen das
begriff den schwerpunkten 90 jährigen
der im sterben liegt den 40 jährigen
familienvater der gerade seine existenz
verloren hat und den 19-jährigen den
seine freundin verlassen hat wir
sprechen über alle diese fälle die
unwiderruflich sterbenskranken leidenden
brauchen hilfe beim sterben
die moderne palliativmedizin bietet
diese hilfe so können auch bei
schwersten krankheitsverläufen die
schmerzen effektiv gelindert werden
es wird hilfe beim sterben geleistet
aber eben nicht hilfe zum sterben die
menschen in akuten lebenskrisen dagegen
brauchen hilfe zum leben
der rückgang der suizidrate in
deutschland in den 80er und 90er jahren
zeigt dass professionelle hilfe und
beratung effektiv leben rettet in fast
allen fällen wir werten die betroffenen
die ihren eigenen versuchten suizid
überlebt haben ihr überleben später als
glück sich das leben zu nehmen ist nach
meiner persönlichen ganz festen
überzeugung kein ausdruck autonome
selbstbestimmung
es ist aller meistens ein akt der
vollständigen verzweiflung
suizidwillige brauchen daher keine
staatlichen angebote zum sterben sondern
menschen die ihnen helfen mit der
förderung der sozialhilfe öffnen wir die
büchse der pandora
in der schweiz hat sich die zahl der
assistierten selbstmord
zwischen 2010 und
18 verdreifacht so zieht forscher und
palliativ mediziner warnen nachdrücklich
davor den assistierten suizid zu
ermöglichen und die bundesärztekammer
und der marburger bund befürchten dass
so die erwartungshaltung entsteht dass
ärzte suizidhilfe leisten müssen
in seiner rede zur bioethik 2001 hat der
damalige bundespräsident johannes rau
eindringlich gewarnt
ich darf zitieren wenn das weiterleben
nur eine von zwei optionen ist wird
jeder rechenschaftspflichtig der anderen
die last seines weiter lebens aufbürdet
zitat ende
gott bewahre uns davor das ist ihr
defizit begründet eine kultur des todes
die sie widerspricht nicht nur
universellen ethischen grundsätzen
sondern auch den werten unserer
christlich abendländischen kultur davon
bin ich zutiefst überzeugt vielen dank
für dein kollege war stolz er tritt von
storch war dass der nächste redner ist
lars castellucci und er gehört auch zu
der gruppe von abgeordneten um ansgar
heveling auch die sich hier dafür
einsetzen das geschäftsmäßige
suizidhilfe grundsätzlich strafbar
bleiben sollen
vielen dank herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und heute
in besonderer weise liebe mitbürgerinnen
und mitbürger die uns zu sehen
das ist eine debatte über das sterben
aber eigentlich ist es eine debatte über
das leben und über das stern
dass ein teil dieses lebens ist und dem
müssen wir uns stellen und das fällt da
nicht leicht sich mit der eigenen
endlichkeit auseinanderzusetzen
und weil das so ist müssen wir uns dafür
zeit nehmen zeit mit so einer
orientierungs debatte aber ich will den
eingangs auch sagen zeit über die
wenigen verbleibenden sitzungswochen
hinaus und nicht schon in dieser
wahlperiode zu einer endgültigen
entscheidung kommen
es gibt einen spruch der wird im
zusammenhang von leben sterben tod gerne
zitiert er heißt alles hat seine zeit
geboren werden hat seine zeit sterben
hat seine zeit pflanzen hat seine zeit
ausreißen was gepflanzt ist hat seine
zeit und so weiter
die wahrheit heute ist allerdings
niemand hat zeit und deswegen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir dürfen nicht nur über fristen reden
über paragrafen wenn es gut gehen soll
beim leben und auch am lebensende dann
brauchen wir andere menschen und die
brauchen eben zeit
eltern für ihre kinder kinder für ihre
eltern pflegekräfte für die kranken für
die älteren ich für dich du für mich nur
so kann es gehen und ein gutes
deutschland von morgen ist eben nicht
nur höher schneller weiter sondern es
ist ein land in dem wir füreinander
einstehen indem wir aufeinander achten
einander respektieren
daran müssen wir arbeiten das
verfassungsgericht hat uns nun einen
auftrag gegeben und ich möchte sagen den
respektiere ich ganz ausdrücklich ich
respektiere die freien willens
freiwillig getroffene entscheidung sich
selbst das leben zu nehmen auch wenn ich
traurig bin jedem einzelnen fall ich
respektiere auch dass dafür die hilfe
anderen anspruch genommen werden kann
aber ich muss doch daraus kein modell
machen denn
wenn es ein modell würde welche
entscheidungen werden dann so freiwillig
künftig noch getroffen dann wird doch
gefragt werden lohnt sich das noch die
nächste operation oder auch nur die
anschaffung dann wachsen erwartungen der
gesellschaft oder ich denke nur sie
könnten da sein dass das häuschen doch
zur pflege nicht drauf gehen soll
oder ich bin nur noch eine last und da
sage ich stopp niemand in diesem land
ist überflüssig und mehr noch niemand in
diesem land soll sich überflüssig fühlen
und deswegen ja zur selbstbestimmten
entscheidungen aber auch bitte kollege
und kollegen darauf achten dass
gesellschaftlich noch nicht noch mehr
ins rutschen gerät deshalb wie noch ich
für schranken verschränken die wir auch
im strafrecht setzen müssen es braucht
schutz der selbstbestimmung auch für
verletzliche gruppen prävention eine
gute versorgung dafür müssen wir jetzt
einen neuen anlauf miteinander wagen
gemeinsam mit kolleginnen und kollegen
von fünf fraktionen lade ich dazu
herzlich ein mitzuwirken vielen dank
daher gelegen
katrin helling klar spricht als nächstes
für die fdp fraktion auch sie hat hier
schon sich in der debatte eingebracht
und zwar hat sie ein an einem
interfraktionellen entwurf gesetzentwurf
mit gearbeitet unter anderem mit karl
lauterbach und petra sitte
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben schließt die
freiheit ein sich das leben zu nehmen
und hierfür bei dritten hilfe zu suchen
so hat es das bundesverfassungsgericht
im vergangenen jahr formuliert 1 gegen
die autonomie gerichteten lebensschutz
so das gericht darf es nicht geben
ich finde wir sollten einen
selbstbestimmten sterbewunsch nicht nur
respektieren wir sollten uns als
gesetzgeber an die seite der menschen
stellen die selbstbestimmt sterben
möchten ein recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben darf es nicht nur auf dem papier
geben es gebietet die menschlichkeit das
selbstbestimmt handelnde betroffene auch
zugang zu medikamenten zur selbsttötung
erhalten und nicht länger entweder ins
ausland gehen oder auf unsicherer und
schmerzhaftere möglichkeiten zur
selbsttötung verwiesen werden wir
sollten deshalb noch in dieser
wahlperiode tätig werden
lassen sie uns ein verständliches und
umfassendes suizidhilfe gesetz auf den
weg bringen das die folgenden fünf
gedanken beherzigt
wir brauchen ein gesetz dass ein
flächendeckendes niederschwelliges
hochwertiges umfassendes und
bevormundung splice beratungsangebot für
jedermann etabliert das ist jedem der
sich aus autonom gebildeten freien
willen heraus entschließt zu sterben
ermöglicht suizidhilfe in anspruch zu
nehmen
das ist im grundsatz erlaubt menschen
die selbstbestimmt gehen möchten zu
helfen
das klarstellt dass jeder auch ein arzt
suizidhilfe leisten darf und dass die
möglichkeit der ärztlichen verschreibung
von mitteln zur selbsttötung für
selbstbestimmt handelnde vorsieht dass
wir uns innerhalb der
verfassungsrechtlichen leitplanken
bewegen müssen sollte selbstverständlich
sein dass sie uns auch deshalb die
freundin den fünf dinge nicht machen
lassen sie uns gedanklich nichts an die
verfassungswidrige norm des § 2 17
strafgesetzbuch anknüpfen
schaffen wir nicht wieder ein
grundsätzliches verbot jeglicher hilfe
und lassen wir die finger vom strafrecht
lassen sie uns nicht an materielle
kriterien wie erkrankungen anknüpfen das
hat uns das bundesverfassungsgericht
explizit untersagen lassen sie uns die
entscheidung über den zugang zu einem
medikament zur selbsttötung nicht zu
einer behördenentscheidung machen
schließlich lassen sie uns die zahl
erforderliche gutachten und
zwischengeschaltete
entscheidungsprozesse und die länge
abzuwarten da fristen nicht so gestalten
dass das recht auf einen
selbstbestimmten tod de facto wieder
leer läuft meine damen und herren wir
müssen sicherungsmaßnahmen ergreifen
aber wir dürfen unsere eigenen
moralvorstellungen nicht über die
individuelle selbstbestimmung stellen
betroffene brauchen keine bevormundung
nicht den erhobenen zeigefinger
sie brauchen unser verständnis vielen
dank winkler und petra sitte von der
linksfraktion spricht als nächstes wie
gesagt hat sie am gleichen gesetzentwurf
mitgearbeitet wie ihre vorrednerin
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
sterbehilfe ist lebenshilfe für menschen
die im verlaufe ihres lebens über dessen
ende nachdenken und die eben vorbereitet
sein wollen
für menschen denen unmittelbar das
sterben vor augen steht weiter zu leben
scheint unmöglich aus welchem grund auch
immer
darüber haben dir nicht zu befinden und
wir haben uns nicht darüber zu erheben
für menschen die andere zeitlebens oder
eben auch am lebensende begleiten und
sich mit ihnen zu sterben und tod
austauschen ob als angehörige ärzte
pflegende oder im freunde jeder oder
jede von uns hegt wohl den wunsch das
sterben keine qual werden möge man
möchte einfach in frieden mit sich
selbst gehen und man möchte sich auch
verabschieden können wir wissen wie in
diesen zeiten dieser wunsch gerade
existenziell wichtig ist um ein leben in
ruhe zu beenden und wie wichtig das für
familien ist
manche nehmen sterben in demut hin aber
die mehrzahl der menschen möchten doch
er mit der vorstellung leben es auch
selbstbestimmt entscheiden zu können
möchten es in der eigenen hand haben und
in dieser hoffnung lassen sich ängste
und ohnmachtsgefühle sehr wohl abbauen
das sterben von dir dann eben auch das
bedrohliche und damit lässt sich ganz
sicher besser leben und deshalb ist für
mich eben sterbehilfe auch lebenshilfe
in diesem sinne hat uns das
bundesverfassungsgericht aufgegeben
ungerechtfertigte eingriffe in das
selbstbestimmungsrecht von menschen
auszuschließen
es geht um rechtssicherheit für
betroffene für angehörige und ärzte seit
2015 bestehen aber unüberwindliche
faktische hürden darf
wir müssen auch die frage klären wie
nach langem nachdenken nach gesprächen
nach beratungen und letztlich eben auch
eine entscheidung der sterbewillige oder
die sterbewillige legal anderen
medikament kommt maßstab unserer
gesetzlichen regelungen meine damen und
herren kann nicht sein
ob der oder die einzelne abgeordnete
hier in diesem hause selbst sterbehilfe
beanspruchen möchte oder es ausschließt
maßstab sollten die werte vorstellungen
und wünsche von menschen im land seien
welche das grundgesetz formuliert und
eben auch schützt
nach diesen werten und in würde leben
und sterben zu können
dafür haben wir hier so weit räume zu
öffnen dass niemand an seiner selbst
bestimmten entscheidungen gehindert wird
oder damit andere in ihrer
entscheidungsfreiheit einschränkt nicht
misstrauen in die entscheidungsfähigkeit
und in die entscheidungskraft von
menschen sollte uns leiten nicht verbote
sondern ergebnisoffene auch präventive
angebote sollten ihnen helfen
meine damen und herren entscheiden wir
uns für gute suizidprävention und
entscheiden wir uns damit auch für
lebenshilfe danke für die aufmerksamkeit
vieler kollegen
[Applaus]
nächster redner eines kollegen renate
künast aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen herr präsident die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat er den
alten § 317 stgb für nichtig erklärt und
sie haben gesagt in jeder lebenslage
wirklich in jeder lebenslage sie haben
nicht nach alter nach krankheit oder was
immer differenziert in jeder lebenslage
so sagt das allgemeine und beinhaltet
das allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht ein
recht auf selbstbestimmte sterben und
sich dabei auch hilfe von dritten zu
holen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat aber
auch gesagt dass der gesetzgeber die
gesetzgeber in das sind wir
schutzvorschriften machen kann und
sterbehilfe regulieren kann
und was mich beeindruckt wenn ich diesen
text nochmal lese dass da auch steht
dass wir einen weg haben müssen ihren
die menschen das recht haben ihren
verfassungsrechtlichen wunsch in
zumutbarer weise zu verwirklichen und es
bewegt mich meine damen und herren hier
ist jetzt über freiheit und dass unser
grundgesetz das leben will ja das stimmt
aber wir haben eben auch dieses
persönlich allgemeine
persönlichkeitsrecht und wir wissen doch
heute nach dieser gerichtsentscheidung
sterbehilfe und beihilfe findet statt
vereine gehen in altersheime und beraten
über das recht am ende des lebens
ärztinnen und ärzte sind damit
konfrontiert meine damen und herren
und da meine ich dass wir es nicht bei
der gerichtsentscheidung belassen können
sondern auch rechtlich eine klare
rechtssichere weg eröffnen müssen
das heißt ein rechtssicheren weg zugang
zu medikamenten die jetzt auf
irgendwelche klandestinen art und weise
und keiner weiß welche eigentlich
genommen werden fassen wir uns ein herz
und machen wir eines nämlich im rahmen
des respekts vor dieser selbstbestimmung
finden wir einen weg der sicher ist und
du bist und ich sage nochmal für fern
castellucci es geht nicht darum ein
modell zu
es findet längst stadtherr customs wurde
dass wir schutz waren drin haben ich
meine es geht ja auch nicht um die frage
ob sie oder ich ob irgendjemand von uns
das richtig findet oder nicht richtig
findet oder ob kirchen religiöse mensch
ist richtig oder nicht und ich finde es
ist ein persönlichkeitsrecht aus
grundgesetz fordert faktisch von uns zu
sagen wie können betroffene ihr recht
auf selbstbestimmte sterben rechtssicher
umsetzt wie können wir den schutzraum
organisieren meine damen und herren der
ort eine solche regelung ist definitiv
nicht das strafgesetzbuch sondern meine
kollegin katja keul und ich haben ja
einen entwurf der von anderen
unterstützt vorgelegt ein eigenes
schutzgesetz das differenziert zwischen
menschen in medizinische notlage und
menschen die aus anderen gründen ihr
leben enden wollen wir sagen nicht der
eine darf der andere darf nicht sondern
die eröffnen unterschiedliche wege und
respektieren das recht beider meine
damen und herren ich will eines
hinzufügen an der stelle
wir sagen auch und ich finde dass man
das regeln muss zu sterbehilfe verein
muss es regeln geben zu der begleitung
muss es regeln geben es muss die
zuverlässigkeit der personen geregelt
werden meine damen und herren
und was auf alle fälle uns bleibt ist
wir können nicht zulassen dass das
bundesverwaltungsgericht gesagt hat es
muss zugang zu betäubungsmittel geben
und der bundesminister sagt es gibt hier
gar keine abwägung ihr sagt immer nein
das können wir nicht akzeptieren möchte
bleibt für mich lassen sie uns einen
rechtssicheren guten sauberen weg finden
und denken wir im übrigen immer dran
365 tage im jahr ist zeit neben dieser
regelung endlich gute prävention und
gute betreuung zu organisieren und zu
finanzieren
ich hoffe sie hat wie eben auch in der
rede angeklungen ist ebenfalls ein
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt wo eben
unterschieden wird zwischen kranken
menschen und anderen fällen bei in
anderen fällen soll das zum beispiel
längere fristen geben
stefan pischinger spricht als müsstest
meine damen und herren die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar sie zu achten
und zu schützen ist verpflichtung aller
staatlichen gewalt dieser grundsatz der
aus artikel 1 des grundgesetzes gilt
auch am ende des lebens deshalb ist die
diskussion wie wir mit schwerkranken und
sterbenden menschen umgehen eine
zentrale frage unseres gemeinwesens in
den letzten jahren hören wir zunehmend
stimmen die am ende des lebens in der
sterbehilfe einen gangbaren ausweg sehen
diesen weg hat in gewisser weise nun
auch das bundesverfassungsgericht
eingeschlagen
in seinem urteil vom 26 220 hat das
gericht das allgemeine
persönlichkeitsrecht und das recht auf
ein selbstbestimmtes sterben und somit
auch die autonomie als ausdruck der
menschenwürde stärker gewichtet als den
schutz des lebens ich bin der
überzeugung der schutz der menschlichen
würde steht nur dann auf festen grund
wenn auch der schutz des lebens bis zum
ende uneingeschränkt gilt
denn wahre autonomie kann es nur geben
wenn sie in einen übergeordneten
gesellschaftlichen grundkonsens
eingebettet ist der einzelne mensch lebt
nämlich nicht nur für sich allein erlebt
mit und für andere
und damit in einer gemeinschaft die auf
das leben ausgerichtet ist
mit der intellektuellen trennung des
einzelnen vom ganzen wird dieser
gesellschaftlichen grundkonsens nun
aufgebrochen
ich bin der auffassung mit der trennung
von lebensschutz und menschenwürde macht
sich am ende eine kultur des todes breit
denn sobald die selbsttötung als
legitimer alternativer weg gewissermaßen
normalität in die gesellschaft erlangt
wird die selbsttötung eine immer
breitere gesellschaftliche akzeptanz
finden damit wird der suizid zu einer
echten alternative meine damen und
herren
und dies kann in bestimmten fällen zur
erwartungshaltungen führen
es besteht dann die konkrete gefahr dass
menschen aufgrund einer
pflegebedürftigkeit oder krankheit das
gefühl bekommen ihren angehörigen durch
eine selbsttötung entlasten zu müssen
aber kann das ein weg sein den die
politik gehen möchte ich selbst habe in
meiner zeit als krankenhaus mediziner
einige zeit auf einer palliativstation
gearbeitet ich weiß dass mit der
modernen palliativmedizin die linderung
von schmerz und leid möglich ist deshalb
bin ich der festen überzeugung dass es
einen viel stärkeren ausbau des hospiz
und palliativ wesens in deutschland
geben muss
[Applaus]
und es bedarf einer psychologischen
betreuung von suizidwilligen um eine
depression oder andere psychische
erkrankung von einem nachhaltigen
sterbewunsch unterscheiden zu können
denn diese entscheidung kann nicht
rückgängig gemacht werden so sehr ein
einzelfall gute gründe für eine
selbsttötung sprechen mögen so muss
politik doch am ende immer das große
ganze im blick behalten
solche politischen entscheidungen haben
gesamtgesellschaftliche auswirkungen und
müssen deshalb intensiv diskutiert
werden ich bin der überzeugung es
braucht jetzt eine intensive inhaltliche
und fachliche debatte die den wert des
lebens verdeutlicht und geeignete
alternativen zur selbsttötung aufzeigt
vielen dank und nächster redner in der
debatte ist volker münch soll der abend
die fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kollegin sehr
geehrte damen und herren das
bundesverfassungsgericht leitet in
seinem urteil das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben mit der
möglichkeit der suizidhilfe aus der
achtung vor der würde des menschen ab
dieser these kann ich nicht zustimmen
das gegenteil halte ich für richtig
nämlich dass die menschenwürde die
achtung und die erhaltung jedes
menschlichen lebens gebietet dies folgt
aus dem christlichen menschenbild albert
schweitzer bezeichnet dies als ehrfurcht
vor dem leben ja niemand will selbst im
sterben leiden oder andere insbesondere
angehörige leiden sehen der assistierte
suizid kann aber kein ausweg aus der not
des leidens und sterbens seien auch mit
einer vorgeschalteten beratungspflicht
wie vereinzelt vorgeschlagen
kann das eine lösung sein
aus meiner sicht danach wäre die
erfolgte beratung eine voraussetzung
dafür sein leben mit hilfe eines dritten
beenden zu können analog zum
schwangerschaftsabbruch also der
beendigung des lebens eines ungeborenen
kindes
es gibt kein recht auf abtreibung
genauso kann es auch kein recht auf
hilfe bei der selbsttötung geben der
assistierte suizid darf nicht zu einer
staatlich geregelten art des sterbens
werden
er darf nicht zu einer normalität werden
die gefahr ist nicht von der hand zu
weisen dass alte und kranke menschen
sich einem zumindest indirekten druck
ausgesät ausgesetzt sehen ihrem leben
ein ende zu bereiten um ihren
angehörigen nicht so last zu fallen
wir dürfen die büchse der pandora nicht
öffnen
schon jetzt geht es ja beim thema
sterbehilfe nicht nur um sterbenskranke
menschen sondern auch um die die aus
verzweiflung nicht mehr leben wollen was
kommt dann als nächstes suizidbeihilfe
bei minderjährigen oder tötung auf
verlangen was ist ja alles schon in
nachbarländern gibt wir haben nicht zu
wenig selbstmorde sondern leider zu
viele gerade auch in corona zeiten der
staat und deshalb auch wie in diesem
hohen hause sollten die voraussetzung
dafür verbessern dass menschen in
scheinbar auswegloser lage geholfen wird
dass sterbenskranken menschen so weit
wie möglich die schmerzen genommen
werden und das sterbende in würde und in
begleitung ihrer angehörigen sterben
können
es müssen also suizidprävention
palliativmedizin und hospizarbeit
gefördert werden
die organisierte beihilfe
zur selbsttötung darf nicht legalisiert
werden
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr kollege günstig
unterbrüche in die aussprache zum
tatzeitpunkt 4
und ich komme zurück zu
tagesordnungspunkt 1 h die zeit für die
namentliche abstimmung ist vorbei ich
frage ist noch an mitglied des hauses
anwesend dass seine stimme nicht
abgegeben hat gut das ist natürlich
überraschend dass so viele kollegen
kollegen kolleginnen und kollegen wir
haben ja zeigt also es ist nicht so dass
wir jetzt in halle sind ich habe heute
auch keinen nachtdienst insofern ich
weiß als präsident der herzen ist das
[Musik]
schön ich war gerade mal ist noch jemand
anwesend der einstimmig haben wir das
ist nicht der fall dann schließlich die
abstimmung mit die schriftführung
schriftführer mit der ausbildung zu
beginnen das ergebnis der
schlussabstimmung wird ihnen später
bekannt gegeben anschließend folgen die
weiteren abstimmungen mit hans reichen
ich komme zurück zur aussprache vier
vereinbarte debatte suizidhilfe
unterteile als nächste rednerin der
kollegin nina scheer aus der
spd-fraktion das wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist jetzt schon mehrfach erwähnt
worden es handelt sich um eine
einschneidende zäsur die wir in sozial
februar erlebt haben durch ein
verfassungsgerichtsurteil und die möchte
noch mal konkretisieren es ist nicht nur
das recht auf selbstbestimmtes sterben
festgestellt worden sondern ein
grundrecht wurde formuliert ein
grundrecht auf selbstbestimmtes sterben
und frau kollegin künast hat er auch
gerade schon erwähnt diese bezeichnung
was ist super und wenn ich wirklich
davon ausgehen dass ich ein grundrecht
habe und dann hinzunehmen dass es
zumutbar sein muss in einem staat so
behandelt zu werden von der gemeinschaft
dass ich eben nicht in unzumutbarer
weise an bahnreisen dem recht auf ein
suizid nachkommen muss dann bedeutet das
irgendwann schlechterdings dass hilfe
gegeben werden muss sonst im verborgenen
sonst ist es in unwürdigen situationen
dass menschen bloß unentdeckt von der
allgemeinheit von der gesellschaft im
versteckten im verborgenen sich das
leben nehmen das ist für mich ausdruck
von unwürdigkeit und auch das
bundesverwaltungsgericht hatte ja in
fällen in denen das so offenkundig war
ja hilfeschreie damit zu verbunden sind
offenkundig ist bei schwerkranken
unheilbar erkrankten menschen also und
mit unheilbaren krankheiten erkrankten
menschen auch zu zweit hier in anträgen
beim bundesministerium mal vorlegt der
wunsch hilfe zu bekommen in form von
auch die medizinisch heute möglichen in
form von betäubungsmitteln
und das ist ja auch ein hilferuf von
vielen menschen die eben in dieser
situation sind und wenn da auch schon
das verwaltungsgericht gesagt haben man
muss im grund genommen in diesen
situationen dann auch den weg eröffnen
ist damals ja auch schon eingegrenzt wie
diese zumutbarkeit zu fassen ist
und letztendlich hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht und jetzt nur
noch klar gezeichnet das wirklich ein
handlungsbedarf ist deswegen könnt uns
diesen handlungsbedarf nicht länger
widersetzen wir sollten es auch nicht
denn auch von der lebensbejahenden warte
heraus muss es doch in aller all unser
interesse muss unser interesse sein dass
die menschen sich an die gemeinschaft
wänden in ihren nöten
und wenn man ein beratungsnetzwerk
aufbaut was eigentlich dann die letzten
die nächste logische konsequenz sein
muss mit begutachtungsverfahren dann
haben wir damit ein andockpunkt und
sollten diesen auch schaffen für alle
menschen die in dieser lebenssituation
sind die mit diesen gedanken unterwegs
sind und da und nur dort können wir
gemeinsam auch für lösungen suchen das
eben menschen die auch wieder
zurückkommen auf den weg des lebens und
den willen des lebens nämlich mit dem
nach den kriterien selbst bestimmt also
autonomen dauerhaft und ernsthaft wieder
zurück wollen auf den weg des lebens das
wir die dann auch erfassen und anders
wenn wir ihnen den weg versperren wir
sagen wir haben kein handlungsbedarf wir
werden hier nichts tun dann werden wir
auch riskieren dass diese menschen
allein gelassen
ihrem leben das ende das ich denke nicht
zurande würde bedeuten wir haben unterm
strich mehr selbstmorde und das will ich
auf jeden fall vermeiden vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist benjamin strasser er
sitzt für die fdp fraktion im bundestag
[Applaus]
seeger präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen selbstbestimmung in allen
lebenslagen dass es nicht nur eine
lebenseinstellung die ich als junger
mensch und liberale habe es ist ein wert
auf denen sich glaube ich ganz viele
kolleginnen und kollegen in diesem haus
zuständigen können denn selbstbestimmung
ist auch ausfluss der würde eines
menschen
und trotzdem ist nicht alles im leben
planbaren auch nicht alles im leben
selbstbestimmt
es gibt situationen die uns
sprichwörtlich aus der bahn werfen
drogenschulden depressionen eine schwere
körperliche erkrankung es sind diese
grenzsituationen im leben die oftmals
mit einer als unerträglich empfunden
lebenssituationen und vor allem einer
tiefen hoffnungslosigkeit einhergehen
hoffnungslosigkeit engt uns ein
und sie führt vor allem zu einer
einschränkung unserer selbstbestimmung
es gibt menschen und ja es gibt menschen
die diese situation als unerträglich
empfinden und sich das leben nehmen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat in
seinem urteil den assistierten suizid
legalisiert aber uns auch vor
schwerwiegende fragen gestellt und diese
frage diskutieren wir aus meiner sicht
noch zu wenig was bedeutet
selbstbestimmte sterben dann konkret und
wie sichern wir als gesetzgeber auch in
grenzsituationen den freien willen des
einzelnen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
sollten nicht den fehler unterliegen
autonomie mit autarken zu verwechseln
menschen sind keine ausfahrt in weesen
und ob wir es wollen oder nicht wir sind
eingebunden in eine gemeinschaft wir
alle werden beeinflusst von unseren
wahrnehmungen um unseren mitmenschen im
positiven wie im negativen
wer also selbstbestimmtes sterben ernst
nimmt der muss menschen gerade in diesen
grenzerfahrung effektiv vor
missbräuchlichem druck durch dritte oder
eine unausgesprochene welt
gesellschaftlichen erwartungshaltung
schützen das muss der anspruch für uns
als gesetzgeber sein
das bundesverfassungsgerichts selber
erkennt in seiner entscheidung an das
von der normalisierung des assistierten
suizid als form einer lebens beendigung
und dem angebot der geschäftsmäßigen
suizidhilfe eine gefahr für die
selbstbestimmung des einzelnen ausgeht
wir sollten deshalb aus meiner sicht
weiter das gebot der geschäftsmäßigen
suizidbeihilfe im strafrecht regeln um
missbrauch von dritten bei der freien
entscheidung des einzelnen effektiv zu
unterbinden
selbstbestimmte sterben ist ohne eine
effektive suizidprävention nicht denkbar
den betroffenen muss klar sein welche
auswege es aus ihrer hoffnungslosigkeit
gibt der zugang zu einem todbringenden
medikament darf nicht einfacher sein als
so palliativ zu sorgen oder zu anderen
angeboten
ein einmaliges beratungsgesprächen die
kollegen ist keine suizide prävention
die bestehenden angebote beispielsweise
der sucht und schuldnerberatung müssen
effektiv ineinandergreifen und zeitnah
zur verfügung steht und ja zur stärkung
der suizidprävention muss diese aber
auch mit konkreten maßnahmen unterlegt
werden
liebe kollegen und kollegen
wir müssen nach dem urteil handeln
wir können die menschen nicht im
ungewissen lassen aber echte
selbstbestimmung im sterben zu
gewährleisten ist ohne ein wirksamer
schutz konzept das vor missbrauch
schützt nicht denkbar
[Applaus]
benjamin strasser war das und ihn wird
vielleicht schon aufgefallen sein es ist
ein ungewöhnliches bild wer hier
klatscht nach dem rednern es ist eben
weil hier die fraktionszwang aufgelöst
sind und es zum beispiel zukommt dass
kathrin vogler wahrscheinlich in die
gleiche stoßrichtung jetzt sticht wie
benjamin strasser weil sie am gleichen
gesetzentwurf am gleichen eckpunkte
papier gearbeitet haben
menschen die nicht mehr leben wollen
befinden sich oft in einer
ausnahmesituation
sie leiden am leben so wie es gerade ist
sei es durch krankheit depression
einsamkeit den verlust von geliebten
menschen oder eine soziale notlage und
im moment sehen sie keinen ausweg
in dieser situation sind sie besonders
verletzlich und müssen vor beeinflusst
und geschützt werden
auch deshalb weil so die zieht gedanken
oft ambivalent und kurzfristig sind und
hat sich am zweiten juni 2015 den
gesetzentwurf mit eingebracht habe den
das hohe haus später mit großer mehrheit
verabschiedet hat ging es mir vor allem
darum dem treiben selbst ernannter
sterbehelfer das treiben selbst
ernannter sterbehelfer zu unterbinden
die aus dem sterbewunsch von menschen
ein zynisches geschäftsmodell machen
damals habe ich ein video besonders
berührt in dem eine mitarbeiterin eines
dieser vereine einem alten mann sein und
den regelrecht bedrängt seine eigenen
bedenken gegen sein vorher geäusserten
suizid wunsch
beiseite zu legen dieses video ist
inzwischen von der website verschwunden
dafür hat sich der mindestpreis für die
dienstleistung sowie zieht auf von
damals 1000 auch heute 2000 euro erhöht
das alleine finde ich schon abstoßen und
empörend genug aber die suizidforschung
sagt auch ganz klar dass allein die
existenz solcher angebote und die
werbung dafür gemacht wird die zahl der
suizide erhöhen können das
verfassungsgericht hat in seinem urteil
grundsätzlich bestätigt dass der staat
die hochrangigen verfassungshüter leben
und autonomie auch mit dem strafrecht
schützen kann
jedoch müsste er sicherstellen dass im
einzelfall jetzt einen zugang zur
freiwillig bereit gestellter suizidhilfe
real eröffnet bleibt deswegen habe ich
darf mit dem paragraf 217 stgb mit einer
ausnahmeregelung genau für solche
einzelfälle zu ergänzen geschäftsmäßige
hilfe zum suizid sollte nur straffrei
bleiben wenn die frei verantwortliche
entscheidung gesichert ist und trotz
beratung über mögliche alternativen
bestehen bleibt
das bedeutet auch dass minderjährigen
und personen die nicht in der lage sind
einen freien willen zu bilden keine
mittel zur selbsttötung verschafft
werden dürfen
gerade vor dem hintergrund unserer
geschichte darf nie wieder möglich sein
das dritte darüber entscheiden ob ein
leben wert ist gelebt zu werden oder
nicht
oder dass menschen dazu gedrängt
benötigt oder auch nur ermuntert werden
den weg in den tod zu wählen
in unserer kapitalistischen gesellschaft
scheint ja alles einen preis zu haben
aber fast nichts mehr einen wert ich
wünsche mir eine gesellschaft in der
jedes leben wertvoll ist und bis zum
ende gelebt werden darf
der tod gehört dazu aber wenigstens
sollte er nicht auf dem freien markt
gehandelt werden
vielen dank frau kollegin vogel ist mir
sehr neues bedauerlicherweise diese hans
die debatte zum tanz papier unterbrechen
und zurückkehren
zu tagesordnungspunkt 1 a und 1 b ich
gebe ihnen das ergebnis dass von den
schritt für schritt führern ermittelt
wurde der name die schlussabstimmung
über den gesetzentwurf der fraktion in
der cdu csu und spd entwurf eines
vierten gesetzes zum schutz der
bevölkerung bei einer epidemischen lage
von aus einer tragweite drucksachen 19
28.000 44 19 28 1692 und 19 28 1932
bekannt abgegebene stimmen garten 656
mit java bestimmt 342 mit nein haben
bestimmt 250 enthaltungen 64 damit ist
der gesetzentwurf angenommen
das sind also nun die verbindlichen
regelungen bundesweit für eine notbremse
für corona gegenmaßnahmen die jetzt hier
im parlament
und es gibt auch ein bisschen applaus
dafür von den abgeordneten
wir kommen will die
entschließungsanträge
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
fdp auf drucksache 28 1761 fordert die
fdp unter anderem das ist eine
innovative test strategie geben soll und
das ist auch zum beispiel nutzt anreize
zur nutzung innovativer hygiene konzepte
geben soll
fdp fraktion mit den stimmen der
fraktionen des hauses abgelehnt
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen die
linke auf drucksache 28 1762 wir stimmen
dem entschließungsantrag fordert die
fraktion der linken unter anderen dass
die nächtlichen ausgangs beschränkungen
wieder zurückgenommen werden oder zum
beispiel auch dass das arbeitslosengeld
1 um drei monate verlängert werden soll
aber auch dieser antrag wurde abgelehnt
28 1732 fort der ausschuss empfiehlt und
der buchstabe b seiner
beschlussempfehlung die ablehnung des
antrags der fraktion die linke
auf druck seiner 24 1453 mit dem titel
corona strategie für besonders
gefährdete menschen zum nutzen der
ganzen gesellschaft
wer stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
er stimmt dagegen
er enthält sich dann ist diese
beschlussempfehlung beiden teile der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen gegen die
stimmen der fraktion die linke
mit den stimmen der fraktionen des
hauses angenommen und der buchstabe c
seiner beschlussempfehlung empfiehlt der
ausschuss die ablehnung des antrags der
fraktion die linke
auch drucksache 25 1882 mit dem titel
lockdown maßnahme durch gesetz nicht
durch verordnungen wer stimmt für die
sich diesem antrag fordert die linke das
eben der bundestag alle substanziellen
entscheidungen trifft und eben nicht in
anderen gremien darüber entschieden wird
die linke auf drucksachen 27 1960 mit
dem titel mehr sicherheit und
lebensqualität mit schnelltests und
selbsttests für alle ja stimmt für diese
beschlussempfehlung hier stimmt dagegen
enthaltung ist diese beschlussempfehlung
und gegen die stimmen der fraktion die
linke und bündnis 90/die grünen
wählerstimmen übrigen fraktionen des
hauses angenommen dass eben nun alle
drei anträge hier abgelehnt wurden wenn
der ausschuss empfohlen hat sie
abzulehnen dann stimmen eben die
abgeordneten über die
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses ab
einer annahme bedeutet also in diesem
fall dass der jeweilige antrag abgelehnt
wurde und damit geht es weiter in der
debatte
herr präsident meine lieben kolleginnen
und kollegen ein begriff ist in der
debatte um die hilfe zur selbsttötung
zentral selbstbestimmung
jeder suizid wunsch verdient
grundsätzlich akzeptanz das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat etwas sehr
wichtiges klargestellt es sagt die
selbstbestimmung von menschen die sich
das leben nehmen wollen kann durch
vielfältige innere und äußere einflüsse
durch drucksituationen gefährdet sein
ein schutzkonzept sichert hier also die
selbstbestimmung
stellen sie sich zum beispiel eine alte
pflegebedürftige frau vor sie hat eine
geringe rente und angst ihren
angehörigen zur last zu fallen und auch
sorge um ihre mühsam zusammengespart
erde
wenn sie über einen suizid nachdenkt
dann würden diese gedanken ausgelöst
sein durch diese sorgen auch seelische
erkrankung
die angst vor autonomie verlust
einsamkeit können solche
drucksituationen sein
das bundesverfassungsgericht spricht
dann von sozialen pressionen und
nützlichkeitserwägungen die dazu führen
können dass sich der assistierte suizid
als normale form das leben zu beenden
insbesondere für alte und kranke
menschen durchsetzt ich meine eine
solche normalisierung darf niemals
eintreten
kein mensch davon skater signal bekommen
sie oder er sei überflüssig oder werde
nicht gebraucht stand der wissenschaft
ist dass die allermeisten suizid wünsche
volatil
also unbeständig sind und genauso kann
ich es aus meiner langjährigen praxis
als ärztin und psychotherapeutin
bestätigen der suizidale gedanken ist
zumeist nicht der wunsch nach dem tod
sondern der wunsch nach einer zäsur
der wunsch nach einer pause vor einer
von einer als unerträglich empfundenen
situation und je leichter der zugang zu
suizid mitteln ist desto häufiger sind
suizide menschen in krisen brauchen
hilfe um aus dieser situation
herauszukommen und wieder selbstbestimmt
leben zu können das kann die
schuldnerinnen beratung die
suchtberatung genauso die ärztliche oder
psychotherapeutische unterstützung sein
die hilfe zum tod hingegen zementiert
das ende
der selbstbestimmung menschen auf dem
sterbebett erleben durch menschliche
zuwendung durch palliative versorgung
das ihre selbstbestimmung gewahrt wird
das bundesverfassungsgericht warnt vor
versorgungslücken die gerade angesichts
des steigenden kostendrucks im pflege-
und gesundheitssystem zu ängsten vor dem
verlust der selbstbestimmung führen und
dadurch suizid entschlüsse fördern
das heißt wir brauchen eine bessere
suizidprävention die hilfe und sie muss
unbedingt eingebettet sein in ein
schutzkonzept nur so kann die
selbstbestimmung jeder und jedes
einzelnen gewahrt werden
ich danke und nächster redner ist
hermann gröhe er war schon mal
gesundheitsminister hat sich also auch
schon mit dem thema beschäftigt und ist
hier auch mitglied der
abgeordnetengruppe die sich hier mit
einem vorschlag schon zu wort gemeldet
hat herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen für mich gehören der respekt
vor der selbstbestimmung des einzelnen
und der schutz des lebens untrennbar
zusammen
denn das leben selbst ist die
voraussetzung für jede selbstbestimmung
der mit der selbsttötung
unwiederbringlich die grundvoraussetzung
schlechthin entzogen wird
ich bedaure daher die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts auch die 2015
hier im bundestag zu 217 strafgesetzbuch
vertreten gegenpositionen wurde vom
bundesverfassungsgericht verworfen
denn der damalige entwurf für ein
suizidhilfe gesetze ausdrücklich vor
die zulässigkeit der suizidhilfe an eine
unheilbare zu unumkehrbar zum tode
führende erkrankung
anzuknüpfen einzig zulässige
voraussetzung für eine rechtmäßige
inanspruchnahme von selbsttötung des
hilfe sei so das
bundesverfassungsgericht
ein autonom gebildeter freier wille von
dem nur bei einer gewissen
dauerhaftigkeit und inneren festigkeit
ausgegangen werden könne
vieles ließe dich dazu sagen hier will
ich mich nur darauf konzentrieren zu
betonen dass auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht ausdrücklich
gefahren für eine solche frei
verantwortliche entscheidung benennt und
jedenfalls insoweit auch ein
schutzkonzept für geboten hält druck von
außen auch durch ein gesellschaftliches
klima abzuwehren sei daher legitim
dazu sei auch grundsätzlich das
strafrecht ein denkbares mittel
wegen dieser gefahren für eine frei
verantwortlichen scheidung und weil es
um leben und tod geht halte ich eine
verortung entsprechende regelung im
strafrecht für geboten
meine damen meine herren das eine selbst
schuld dass ein selbst tötungswillen
einer frei verantwortlichen entscheidung
und spricht lässt sich nicht leicht
feststellen aus hospizen und
pflegeeinrichtungen wissen wir dass sich
der wunsch zu sterben und der wunsch
weiterzuleben immer wieder abwechseln
können und welche segensreiche wirkung
palliativ und hospizversorgung hier
entfalten können
uns eint alle der wille diese angebote
auch angebote der suizidprävention
weiter auszubauen
es steht einer solidarischen
gesellschaft gut zu gesicht menschen
auch in krisen zum leben zu ermutigen
meine damen und herren
und dazu gehört zu einer solchen kultur
der ermutigung zum leben
nicht nur dass nicht der einzelne zur
selbsttötung hilfe gezwungen werden darf
dies alle positionen anerkennt sondern
dass auch einrichtungen verbindlich für
ihre mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
festlegen können dass solche angebote
nicht zu ihrem selbstverständnis gehören
ich weiß dass nicht nur kirchliche
einrichtungen sondern viele hospize
darauf großen wert legen
meine damen meine herren vor uns stehen
schwere entscheidung und ich will ein
persönliches dilemma bekennen jedes
verfahren das wir brauchen um etwa
seelisch erkrankte menschen zu schützen
birgt die gefahr in sich einer gewöhnung
an selbsttötungen hilfe das ist ein
schweres dilemma über das wir sicher
noch viele diskussionen führen und am
ende eine schwierige entscheidung
treffen müssen herzlichen dank der
bundesgesundheitsminister war 2015 als
damals das gesetz zur sterbehilfe
verabschiedet wurde und der aktuelle
gesundheitsminister den sehen wir jetzt
jens spahn schaut hier aus den reihen
der abgeordneten der debatte zu und der
nächste redner in dieser debatte ist
norbert kleinwächter aus der fdp
fraktion
werter herr präsident sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen haben wir die
macht regelungen über leben und tod zu
treffen dürfen und sollten wir
biopolitik im eminenten sinne betreiben
ich finde nein das leben und der tod
müssen sich politische entscheidung
entziehen
meine damen und herren wie wollen wir
denn sinnvolle regelungen treffen wann
wer für assistierte assistierten suizid
qualifiziert ist wie wollen wir diese
souveräne entscheidungskompetenz an eine
stelle delegieren die erfahrung zeigt
leider dass wenn politische
entscheidungen getroffen werden
dieser oft zu gunst des todes getroffen
werden wir sehen das an den hohen
abtreibungs raten wir sehen das auch an
unseren nachbarländern niederlande und
belgien wo die suizidhilfe gestattet ist
und wo sie mittlerweile zwei prozent
aller todesfälle ausmacht und meine
damen und herren wenn ihr bio
politischer entscheidungen per sie
abnehmen
dann gibt es nur zwei richtungen in die
wir gehen können die einrichtung ist
jeder absoluten freiheit und der
absoluten autonomie das wäre quasi das
persönlichkeitsrecht absolut gesetzt und
die andere richtung ist die möglichkeit
des lebensschutzes die verantwortung vor
gott und den menschen die auch in der
präambel unseres grundgesetzes verfasst
ist und aus meiner tiefsten überzeugung
aus meinem gewissen auch aus meinem
glauben heraus möchte ich sie bitten den
weg des schutzes des lebens zu gehen
das wird auch umso deutlicher wenn wir
uns anschauen was suizid wünsche
tatsächlich eigentlich sind und einige
kollegen haben es kommen wir schon
ausgeführt
sie entstehen oft aufgrund schwerer
erkrankungen psychischer oder physischer
natur auch auf chronische erkrankungen
oder auch manchmal aufgrund des gefühls
nicht mehr gebraucht zu werden
vielleicht jemanden zur last zu fallen
vielleicht sogar einen kosten
faktor zu sein aber wenn wir über
krankheiten sprechen
dann müssen wir darüber sprechen wie wir
sie lindern können wie wir sie heilen
können und wenn wir das noch nicht
adäquat genug wissen dann sollten wir in
forschung investieren wir sollten unsere
hospiz angebote ausbauen unsere
palliativ angebote ausbauen
unsere hilfen anbauen ausbau wir sollten
brücken ins leben bauen und nicht
drücken zum tod
und genau eine solche brücke zum tod ist
aber gerade zum beispiel eine
organisierte suizidhilfe was ist denn
das für ein modell
man zahlt 2000 euro dafür bekommt man
eine beratung und ein mittel mit dem man
sich selbst töten kann meine damen und
herren das senkt jede hemmschwelle je
verfügbar
der tod wird desto häufiger wird er auch
gesucht werden
meine damen und herren gerade im suizid
die software will zum leben tatsächlich
am größten das zeigen überlebens
berichte von zwei männern die sich von
der golden gate bridge gestürzt haben
können ball drinnen und kevin heinz und
sie sagten
just in dem moment an dem sie die reling
losgelassen hatte haben sie das zutiefst
bereut sie sagt da war der wille zum
leben am größten in diesen drei sekunden
vor dem aufprall weil sie erkannt haben
dass es irre war dass es der größte
fehler ihres lebens war
lassen sie uns nicht eine kultur der
ottonen tötung sondern eine kultur des
lebens zu pflegen
haben sie vielen dank sein rechter hat
hier seine befürchtung geäußert dass der
tod wenn er verfügbarer ist häufiger als
option genutzt werden kann der suizid
der bundestag diskutiert in einer
vereinbarten debatte zur suizidhilfe
nächster redner ist teil gelehnt für die
spd fraktion
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
ich bin hier ganz kurzfristig rednern
viel berechtigte als ich wäre einer der
initiatoren eines der gesetzesentwurf
für die im raum stehende auto brachte
aber kurzfristig heute nicht teilnehmen
kann
deshalb werde ich der gerungen hat um
diese positionen das etwas tentative
vielleicht zögern hat zu tun aber
dennoch diesen gesetzentwurf begründen
und stelle fest und das tut unserem
parlament glaube ich auch gut dass wir
eine sehr ernsthafte und würdevolle
debatte führen quer auch zu
parteipolitischen grenzen
ich könnte es mir einfach machen und
jetzt das beispiel einer person nennen
für die die aktuelle situation als
sterbewillige unerträglich ist und die
sie vor grausame hürden stellt um meine
position zu begründen aber ich tue das
bewusst nicht sondern ich nenne das
beispiel einer frau die ich jetzt seit
vielen jahren begleiten darf wie sie
nach deutschland gekommen ist wie wir
als sie wirklich kurz vor dem tode waren
ihre eltern her geholt haben gegen folge
einer genmutation erst ein glioblastom
hat und viele krebserkrankung und die
wie sie nur kann kämpft zu leben es wäre
für sie unvorstellbar aus dem leben
selbst zu schaden oder sich dabei
assistieren zu lassen
das muss man zutiefst respektieren und
auch bei jeder gesetzgebung dafür sorgen
dass sie frei ist gerade in dieser
entscheidung
dennoch gibt es eben aber auch die
anderen ist anders sehen und ich glaube
steht uns nicht zu maßstäbe allein
entwickeln zu wollen das wären
selbstbestimmung keine wirkliche
selbstbestimmung ist das finde ich
anmaßend und es gibt auch die situation
und wir müssen uns glaube ich auch
verdeutlichen dass in der gegenwärtigen
lage und da liegt
auch der auftrag des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes menschen vor
unerträgliche situation gebracht werden
und gestellt werden sich medikamente zu
beschaffen und ziel und auch gerade
deswegen befürworte ich eine
entsprechende gesetzgebung zur
suizidhilfe sollte es doch seien diese
organisation die es gegen bezahlung zu
machen aus dem weg zu räumen das müsste
aus meiner sicht auch ziel eines solchen
weges seien legale wege zu schaffen
autonom im vollbesitz seiner kräfte frei
entscheiden zu können aber auch mit
einer entsprechenden beratungs
infrastruktur und die halte ich nicht
für trivial sondern für ernsthaft und
wir haben ja auch fälle wo beratung
funktioniert ich finde es falsch das
einfach so weg zu tun und das ist
keineswegs eine aufforderung oder ein
anreiz zu sterben und andererseits auch
denjenigen die assistieren wollen die
möglichkeit zu geben es geht nicht um
ein muss der assistenz sondern ein dürfe
und es geht auch nicht um eine
verpflichtung und diejenigen die meinen
dass durch so eine solche gesetzgebung
ein automatismus entstehen würde ihren
glaube ich ich denke es liegt an uns als
gesellschaft und als gesetzgeber wege zu
finden denjenigen die wirklich frei die
entscheidung treffen sterben zu wollen
das zu
und gleichzeitig nicht diejenigen unter
druck zu setzen die das nicht tun wollen
deshalb ist diese gesetzgebung
mitnichten deckungsgleich mit dem
schrecken dem wir unter dem falschen
furchtbaren begriff euthanasie kennen
und ich glaube dass es mein letztes wort
das vielleicht auch gerade dieses thema
ein solches wäre um stärker noch die
bürgerschaft in form von beteiligung
einzubeziehen und deshalb eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche debatte zu
organisieren denn es ist eine zutiefst
autonome aber letztlich auch eine
gesellschaftliche frage über die wir
heute sprechen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster gegner ist der kollege dr
wieland schinnenburg aus der fdp
fraktion
herr präsident meine damen und herren im
alter sieburg hat es hieß es ganz
unmissverständlich ich werde niemandem
auf seine bitte hin
tödliches gift verabreichen und nicht
einmal dazu raten
zitat ende 2000 jahre später heißt es
beim präsidenten der bundesärztekammer
so wiederum zitat sterbehilfe ist keine
ärztliche aufgabe zitat ende
adam carroll dann denkt man darüber nach
was denn ärztliche aufgaben sind und
schraube dazu in die musterberufsordnung
der bundesärztekammer dort heißt es auf
dem des arztes ist es gesundheit zu
schützen sondern wieder herzustellen
leiden zu lindern und sterbenden
beizustehen
also auch die bundesärztekammer sagt
beim sterben darf der arzt nicht abseits
stehen und haben sterben ist etwas
endgültiges und auf was unvermeidlich
ist wir alle haben den tod vor augen
unseren tod vor augen wie alle sehen uns
danach im zeitpunkt des sterbens nicht
allein zu sein
wir sehen uns danach unsere liebsten bei
uns zu haben aber wir sehen uns auch
danach einen arzt bayern zu haben
also nicht nur deshalb weil uns
schmerzen leben sollen sollen wir uns
taktvoll aber auch ehrlich sagen soll
dies um uns steht das meine damen und
herren ist die aufgabe des arztes des
ehrlichen verschwiegenen und
professionellen helfern und diese rolle
musste arzt immer aus vom ersten bis zum
letzten atemzug seines patienten
dazu gehört schwerste entscheidung mit
dem patienten zusammen zu treffen ihn zu
beraten wenn es darum geht gefährliche
operationen vornehmen zu lassen wenn es
darum geht sehr gefährliche medikamente
mit gravierenden nebenwirkungen
zu nehmen meiner die kammer nur meinen
dass das ein arzt machen soll ihm auch
schlimmste diagnose mitteilen soll das
war abseits stehen soll wenn es um den
freitod geht man damit deren das kann
ich ehrlich gesagt nicht verstehen ich
bin der meinung ein arzt sollte immer
bei seinen patienten seien und immer
nicht nur ein offenes ohr haben auch
immer für ihn da sein und wenn der
patient wohl überlegt sein freitod
wünscht denn darf es im arzt auf keinen
fall verboten sein
diese letzte warmherzige hilfe zu
leisten meine damen und herren das
arzt-patienten-verhältnis ist
ich weiß dass medizinrechtler davon
geprägt dass der wille des patienten das
entscheidende ist das gilt überall
wieso also noch ausständig hier gerade
nicht gelten meine damen und herren
der staat greift schon oft genug in das
arzt patient verhältnis 1
ich möchte nicht dass der staat auch
noch ärzten verbietet diese letzte
barmherzige hilfe zu leisten
diese richtung sollten wir denken vielen
dank meine damen und im nächste rednerin
in dieser debatte ist gesine lötzsch aus
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren jeder mensch
hängt am leben und jeder mensch hat das
recht auf selbstbestimmung und seinen
freien willen
in der bundestagsdebatte von 2015 zum
thema sterbehilfe wurde alles gesagt was
gesagt werden musste
und es gibt ein klares urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes was ich nicht
kritisieren sondern sehr gut finde meine
damen und herren und das
bundesverwaltungsgericht hat der
regierung schon 2017 klare vorgaben für
das verfahren gemacht über den erhalt
der täglichen gabe entscheidet das
bundesinstitut für arzneimittel und
medizinprodukte
doch die bundesregierung boykottiert
dieses urteil
ich finde das nicht akzeptabel kann doch
nicht sein dass die bundesregierung nun
dient urteil umgesetzt die hier
ideologisch gefallen meine damen und
herren das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes ist klar und
eindeutig dem gericht zufolge umfasst
das allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht in
verbindung mit der menschenwürde als
ausdruck persönliche autonomie ein recht
auf selbstbestimmte sterben und das
schließt auch das recht ein sich das
leben zu nehmen
das verbot in paragraph 217
strafgesetzbuch mache es den
suizidwilligen faktisch unmöglich die
von ihnen gewählte geschäftsmäßig
angebotene suizidhilfe in anspruch zu
nehmen so dass es dem einzelnen faktisch
keinen raum zur wahrnehmung seiner
verfassungsrechtlich geschützten
freiheit gibt meine damen und herren ich
habe den eindruck dass die
bundesregierung damals beginnt mit herr
gröhe als er noch minister war dann den
staffelstab an jens spahn über gebend
alles tut um die durchsetzung dieses
urteils zu verhindern
ich kann über die beweggründe nur
spekulieren
ich habe den eindruck dass sie meinen
sie wissen besser was den menschen gut
tut
die das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
aber ganz einfach erkannt dass diese
weltsicht dem selbstbestimmungsrecht des
menschen widerspricht
meine damen und herren ich will ein
gesetz das das selbstbestimmungsrecht
der menschen stärkt ich will dass
sterbende vor skrupellosen
geschäftemachern geschützt werden
und ich will dass ärzten und ärzte nicht
länger in einer juristischen grauzone
arbeiten müssen meine damen und herren
und augen
das ist unschwer erkennbar unterstütze
ich den gesetzesentwurf von dr petra
sitte dr karl lauterbach und anderen und
hoffe dass wir gemeinsam entsprechend
den vorgaben des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes hier zu einer
lösung kommen die der würde der
selbstbestimmung und den freien willen
entspricht vielen dank
soweit der vertretungs vorsitzende der
linksfraktion im bundestag sie hat auch
die situation der ärzte angesprochen
ärzte müssen das standesrecht beachten
in ihrem tun allerdings ist das je nach
bundesland und kammern unterschiedlich
auch da gibt es stimmen die eben eine
einheitliche regelung fordern
katja keul spricht jetzt vor sechs
jahren stand ich hier und habe als
minderheitenposition die geltende
rechtslage zur sterbehilfe verteidigt
nach dem motto wenn es nicht notwendig
ist ein gesetz zu machen ist es
notwendig kein gesetz zu machen
das gilt erst recht für das strafrecht
den schärfsten schwert des staates das
nur als ultima ratio also als letztes
mittel zum einsatz kommen darf
das verfassungsgericht war in seiner
entscheidung deutlicher als ich es je zu
hoffen gewagt hatte sterbehilfe ist
aufgrund des urteils in deutschland
wieder möglich und wird auch praktiziert
und dennoch stehe ich heute hier und
vertrete einen gesetzesentwurf zur
sterbehilfe die nicht gemeinsam mit der
kollegin renate künast verfasst habe das
ist zugegebenermaßen erklärungsbedürftig
warum also tue ich das
erstens der zugang zu pentobarbital als
sichersten tödlichen mitte wird den
sterbewilligen nach wie vor verwehrt
trotz eines urteils des
bundesverwaltungsgerichts hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister mit seinem
nichtanwendungserlass die betroffenen im
regen stehen lassen
wir wollen daher den gesetzlichen zugang
und den anspruch auf die verschreibung
von pentobarbital zum zwecke der
selbsttötung fest schreiben zweiter
aktuell beurteilen sterbehelfer selbst
ob der sterbewunsch auf einer freien
unbeeinflussten willensbildung beruht
oder nicht wir wollen mit unserem
gesetzentwurf für das vier-augen-prinzip
verankern und die zulassung von
sterbehilfe vereinen an bestimmte
kriterien binden
ja was ist eine einschränkende
reglementierung aber das ist legitim
auch im sinne des verfassungsgerichtes
das ausdrücklich betont hat dass wir als
gesetzgeber den berechtigten sorgen vor
missbrauch oder übervorteilung
durch ausgestaltung des verfahrens
rechnung tragen können
dritter anders als andere wollen wie ein
differenziertes verfahren vorsehen
je nachdem ob ein sterbewillige sich in
einer medizinische notlage befindet oder
schlicht aus anderen gründen sein leben
beenden will
in einer medizinischen notlage stehen in
der regel die behandelnden ärzte und
ärztinnen in der verantwortung die unter
einbeziehung einer weiteren kolleginnen
der lage einzuschätzen vermögen die lage
einzuschätzen vermögen ein sterbewillige
jenseits der medizinische notlage hat
allerdings keine ärztin an seiner seite
und es ist auch kaum vorstellbar dass
sich ärztinnen finden die in solchen
fällen bereit wären sterbehilfe für
einen gesunden menschen zu leisten
hier braucht es also einen zusätzlichen
weg wenn wir diesen menschen den zugang
zur sterbehilfe nicht gravieren wollen
deswegen schlagen wir hier eine
verpflichtende beratung durch eine
unabhängige beratungsstelle vor
diese beratungsstellen müssen geeignet
es qualifiziertes personal zu halten und
dürfen die beratungen nur bescheinigen
wenn sie keinen mängel bei der
willensbildung des sterbewilligen
feststellen können außerdem müssen zwei
beratungen in einem zeitlichen
mindestabstand stattfinden um die
dauerhaftigkeit des sterbewunsch ist zu
dokumentieren eine solche
pflichtberatung trägt im übrigen auch
zur suizidprävention bei am ende
eröffnet die bescheinigung einer solchen
beratungsstelle dann den anspruch auf
den bezug des tödlichen mittels
unabhängig von einer medizinische
notlage so regeln wir die sterbehilfe
jenseits des strafrechtes in einem
rahmen der den sterbewilligen einen
gewissen schutz bietet den sterbe
helfern eine gewisse rechtssicherheit
und die selbstbestimmung am lebensende
achtet vielen dank
zwei jahre hatte der bundestag
diskutiert bevor im november 20.15 die
geschäftsmäßige förderung der
selbsttötung unter strafe stellte und
einer der bekanntesten vertreter in
dieser debatte war michael brandt und er
wird jetzt auch wieder sprechen für die
unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen diese
debatte wurde erforderlich weil die
reform zur sicherung der
selbstbestimmung von sterbewilligen die
wir im jahr 2015 mit überwältigender
mehrheit fraktionsübergreifend hier und
nach einer langen gesellschaftlichen
debatte beschlossen hatten vom
bundesverfassungsgericht in einem sehr
ungewöhnlichen urteil verworfen wurde
dabei wurde nicht nur das unbestrittene
via existierende recht auf assistenz
beim suizid weit ausgedehnt es wurde
zudem ein schutzkonzept verlangt dass
menschen in wohlhabenden
lebenssituationen vordruck schützen soll
und das teils im klaren widerspruch zum
urteil liegt das fundamentale urteil mit
all seinen widersprüchen ist gesprochen
und die wurden dem parlament zur lösung
überlassen
hier wird nicht weniger verlangt als die
quadratur des kreises
es bleibt unsere aufgabe autonomie und
selbstbestimmung nicht nur formal
sondern real zu schützen
denn niemand von uns könnte sich der
verantwortung entziehen falls ein zu
schwacher schutz gegen missbrauch dazu
führt dass wegen der ausweitung selbst
auch der geschäftsmäßigen suizidbeihilfe
nun menschen dem druck nachgeben und
getötet werden selbst gegen den eigenen
willen
wir haben also und das ist die büchse
der pandora die das urteil geöffnet hat
diese neue qualität der bedrohung des
lebens von menschen in schwerer notlage
während die reform von 2015
zuallererst den schutz und die
selbstbestimmung von wohlhabenden
personen im blick hatte haben andere vor
allem diejenigen im blick die ohne
weitere auflagen ihrem leben aus freier
selbstbestimmung ein ende setzen wollen
ohne dass es die antwort gibt wie die
frei verantwortlichkeit die
dauerhaftigkeit eigentlich konkret
festgestellt werden können
und das ist nicht weniger als ein echter
paradigmenwechsel die schwachen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sind zumeist
auch die stillen die stummen denen eine
stimme zu geben sie nicht schutzlos dem
druck leicht verfügbarer sprichwörtlich
tödlicher angebote auszuliefern
das bleibt vor unserer geschichte und
unserer verfassung unsere wichtigste
aufgabe
niemand darf auch nicht versehentlich
säulen weg räumen die die gesamte statik
des und rechts auf selbstbestimmung auch
am lebensende zusammenbrechen lassen
können
unsere verantwortung bleibt wir müssen
die schwachen vor allem schützen weil
wir eine gesellschaft mit menschlicher
qualität bleiben wollen
an fragen wie diesen entscheidet sich
auch katalytisch weit über die frau
einzelfrage hinaus in welche richtung
eine gesellschaft auf dauer geht
zwischen diesem fundamentalen urteilen
und dem grundrecht auf leben die
richtige antwort zu finden das ist
tatsächlich die quadratur des kreises
und umso mehr müssen wir jedes detail
jeden grundsatz sehr sorgfältig
daraufhin überprüfen dass wir nicht
einen einzigen menschen unfreiwillig in
den tod getrieben sehen das sind wir
diesen menschen und auch uns selbst
schuldig
[Applaus]
darauf michael brands folgt thomas seitz
er ist für die fw fraktion hier im
deutschen bundestag und wie so viele
abgeordnete von beruf jurist
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe zuschauer allen
mandatsträgern ist klar wie ernst das
thema ist weil es sowohl extrem
menschliche situation überhaupt berührt
uns allen muss klar sein dass es keine
gesetzliche regelung geben wird die
allen welt anschauen und lebensentwürfen
gleichermaßen entspricht aber wir haben
eine gemeinsame diskussionsgrundlage und
die hat sogar bereits gesetzeskraft das
bundesverfassungsgericht nämlich hat
festgestellt das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben erstreckt sich
auch auf die entscheidung des einzelnen
sein leben eigenhändig zu beenden
daran müssen wir anknüpfen wir reden
nicht über sterbehilfe
es geht nicht um tötung auf verlangen
und schon gar nicht um euthanasie auch
nicht um behandlungsabbruch unser
einziges thema heute ist die suizidhilfe
also der wunsch nach unterstützung bei
der beendigung des eigenen lebens wieder
lassen sie uns das sachlich feststellen
damit wir überhaupt dem schwierigen
thema gerecht werden können ohne polemik
es geht um die selbstbestimmung des
menschen am ende seines lebens natürlich
gibt es da auch die gefahr des
missbrauchs
deshalb muss ja die selbstbestimmung
gerade geregelt werden aber ich erinnere
an einen grundsatz akkus montolivo
summen der missbraucht hebt den ich
ergänze rechtmäßigen gebrauch nicht auf
so schafft man eben einfach das erbrecht
ab nur weil es menschen gibt die
vielleicht ihren erbonkel umbringen
wollen also gesetzliche regelung ist
notwendig tabuisierung hilft keinen zum
verfassungsmäßigen recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben gehört auch der
wunsch nach einem selbstbestimmten
todeszeitpunkt auch das ist zu
respektieren ein rechtsstaat sei
schreibt seinen bürgern nicht vor wie
das lebensende auszusehen hat denn
individueller und persönlicher kann
keine entscheidung sein
ein anderer gesichtspunkt es heißt zu
recht wohl und hasselroth isopren alex
der wille des kranken ist das höchste
gesetz das weiß jeder
verantwortungsbewusste arzt und keiner
macht es sich einfach mit seiner
entscheidung
der mensch der freiwillig aus dem leben
gehen will hat auch ein recht auf
respekt ein system dass hier die hilfe
verweigert und den hilfswilligen
mediziner bestraft wird auch dazu dass
es menschen gibt die sich vorzüge werfen
oder in den autoverkehr hinein rasen das
ist schrecklich und das kann nicht im
interesse einer humanen gesellschaft
sein
kein arzt machte sich leicht mit dem tod
und verantwortungsvollen ärzten sollte
es deshalb erlaubt sein
unter festgelegten bedingungen als
helfer in der not zu wirken auch beim
lebensende
die bedingungen müssen allerdings
sicherstellen dass das sterbewunsch
ernsthaft ist und auf einer freien
willens entscheidung beruht er darf
weder abschreckend noch verhindert aber
auch nicht einladend wirken möchte
schließt mit einer persönlichen
erinnerungen aus der verhandlung beim
bundesverfassungsgericht ist mir
besonders eine schilderung im gedächtnis
geblieben
die sichere gewissheit dass er mit
assistierten suizid jederzeit sein
sterbewunsch würde umsetzen können hat
einen betroffenen die kraft gegeben
seine krankheit weit länger zu ertragen
als ursprünglich für ihn vorstellbar
selbst wenn final viele davon keinen
gebrauch machen für viele menschen wird
das wissen um die reine möglichkeit
schon ausreichen um schmerz und angst zu
verringern und zu ertragen und das
erscheint mir human zu sein
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
bürgermeister thomas ist salz kerstin
griese spricht als nächstes sie ist
parlamentarische staatssekretärin beim
bundesminister für arbeit und soziales
spricht aber in dieser vereinbarten
debatte als abgeordnete
deswegen kommt sie auch nicht von der
regierungsbank sondern aus den reihen
der spd fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren
2015 hat der deutsche bundestag nach
intensiver debatte und mit einer sehr
großen mehrheit beschlossen den
geschäftsmäßigen also auf wiederholung
angelegten assistierten suizid mit dem
paragraf 217 unter strafe zu stellen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat dieses
gesetz am 26 februar 2020 aufgehoben
dieses urteil ist zu respektieren und
wir haben uns intensiv damit beschäftigt
was daraus folgt das gericht hat den
gesetzgeber aufgefordert zu klären wie
das selbstbestimmungsrecht des einzelnen
gesichert werden kann
und für mich ist ganz wichtig
selbstbestimmung heißt schutz vor druck
schutz vor einer schweren irreversiblen
entscheidung denn es geht in diesem fall
um leben und tod
eine einsame als er damals schwer
kranker mann der zu hause von seinen
angehörigen gepflegt wird ein
bettlägeriger im pflegeheim ein seit
vielen jahren pflegen pflegebedürftiger
schwerst behinderter mensch ein mensch
in einer schweren depressiven phase sie
alle haben das recht auf
selbstbestimmung und das recht vor
fremdbestimmten und über alten sterbe
wünschen geschützt zu werden
selbstbestimmung kann ohne den schutz
der schwachen nicht funktionieren das
selbstbestimmungsrecht des einzelnen
endet dort wo das recht auf das leben
eines anderen in frage gestellt wird und
die achtung vor dem leben auch vor dem
leidenden dem schwerkranken den
behinderten leben gehört zur
selbstbestimmung dazu menschen menschen
extrem leiden situationen dürfen nicht
in eine situation geraten sich
rechtfertigen zu müssen wenn sie
angebote zum beispiel von sogenannten
sterbehilfe vereinen ablehnen niemals
darf sich jemand dafür rechtfertigen
müssen dass er oder sie weiterleben will
für mich ist klar dass es das geschäft
mit dem tod und werbung dafür nicht
geben darf deshalb darf es mit beihilfe
im rahmen des grundgesetzes nur dann
geben wenn die selbstbestimmung durch
umfassende beratung und begutachtung
sichergestellt und vor allem und
zuallererst mit angeboten der
suizidprävention verbunden ist
denn wir wissen von vielen forschung und
erfahrung der psychiatrie der palette
die medizin und der seelsorge dass ein
sterbewunsch sich oft und manchmal sogar
sehr schnell wieder ändert und dass er
fast immer ein hilferuf ist so nicht
weiterleben zu wollen auf einen
sterbewunsch und auch die ängste von
menschen vor schmerz und leid ist die
richtige antwort eben nicht der gift
bücher auf dem nachttisch für den
einsamen suizid sondern wir haben
patientenverfügungen die sichern dass
der wille des patienten gilt niemand
muss behandlung mit sich machen lassen
die er oder sie nicht will keine
therapie auch kein künstliches weiter
nehmen die angst vor schmerzen kamen mit
den inzwischen sehr weit entwickelten
möglichkeiten der palliativmedizin
beantwortet werden niemand darf und
niemand soll qualvoll sterben und die
angst vor einsamkeit können wir nicht
mit einem gesetz nehmen sondern dafür
brauchen wir eine sorgende gesellschaft
und das geht jeden menschen jeden tag an
wir haben die pflicht uns nur die
selbstbestimmung des einzelnen blick zu
haben sondern auch die auswirkungen auf
unser zusammenleben auf das
gesellschaftliche klima und ich
befürchte dass eine verhängnisvolle neue
normalität entstehen kann in der der
assistierte suizid zum normalfall werden
kann wenn wir bundesweit 40
beratungsstellen aufbauen wie es andere
entwürfe fordern und unserer
nachbarländer zeigen wohin uns dieser
weg führt wenn der assistierte suizid
erleichtert wird die zahlen steigen dann
nicht nur schwerstkranke wollen die
möglichkeit in anspruch nehmen in
einigen ländern ist auch die aktive
sterbehilfe die in deutschland ja nach §
116 verboten ist der normalfall geworden
deshalb müssen wir auf suizid prävention
setzen die antwort muss sein für
menschen im alter psychischen krisen bei
krankheiten hilfe und unterstützung und
zuwendung und der satz ich will sterben
ist immer einer der vom gegenüber
verlangt sich zeit zu nehmen zeit nach
den gründen zu fragen zeit für hilfe und
zuwendung und dann kann es auch immer
athletischer einzel entscheidung geben
aber ich möchte in einer sorgen und
solidarischen gesellschaft leben und ich
unterstütze deshalb den antrag den
ansatz der kolleginnen kollegen lars
castellucci ansgar heveling kirsten cup
konnte benjamin strasser ann kathrin
vogler ist es gut dass wir uns aus allen
die fraktionen zusammen gefunden haben
und die bestmöglichen konsequenzen aus
dem urteil zu entwickeln damit die würde
des lebens und die selbstbestimmung die
immer zusammengehören
vielen dank glauben sie mir ich weiß
dass ich das extrem unsolidarisch finde
von ihnen haben es auch zwei minuten
geeinigt sie haben vier minuten zehn
sekunden gesprochen
trotz meiner mehrfachen hinweise alles
gut ich bin gerade bei der debatte das
nicht unterbrechen oder das wunder
gemessen hat da wir sollten uns
vielleicht noch an die regeln halten
die ermahnung von wolfgang kubicki
pascal kober wird jetzt als nächstes
sprechender evangelischer pfarrer ist
und auch als militärseelsorger schon
gearbeitet hat der präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich möchte
meine klappe messende redezeit in dieser
debatte den angehörigen von suizidenten
widmen
dazu ist suizid eines menschen bleibt
und das darf ich ihn als seelsorger
sagen
das wissen sie auch alle nicht folgenlos
für das leben und auch für die freiheit
der nahen angehörigen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat das
selbstbestimmungsrecht des einzelnen
betont seinem ganz persönlichen wunsch
sterben zu wollen erfüllen zu können
dem müssen wir rechnung tragen und das
hat die sorge betont dass
gesellschaftliche werte sich verändern
können
dem wollen wir auch sorge tragen was
aber außerhalb des blickfeldes geblieben
ist ist die frage welche folgen sich für
angehörige geben könnten auch übrigens
für angehörige die den suizid wunsch des
betroffenen unterstützen
der wissenschaftliche fach des chors
geht von im schnitt sechs personen aus
die von einem suizid betroffen sind für
deren leben der freitod ihres nächsten
einen tiefen einschnitt in ihr leben
bedeutet
es geht um menschen die ihren partner
verlieren
es geht um eltern die ihre kinder
verlieren es geht um kinder die ihre
eltern verlieren es geht um geschwister
die ihre geschwister verlieren
und was wäre unser wunsch wenn es um
unseren partner gebe als der dass der
sterbewunsch so sorgfältig wie nur
möglich geprüft würde und dass
missbrauch so sorgfältig wie nur möglich
verhindert wird und liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen was bedeutet es eigentlich
einen menschen mehrere wochen zu
begleiten der einen sterbewunsch in
seinem herzen trägt vielleicht sogar
schon das rezept für das medikament in
seiner tasche gibt es beratungsangebote
unterstützungsangebote für die
angehörigen
lassen wir sie mit ihren fragen den
sorgen ängsten eventuell schuldgefühlen
und traumata allein erschöpft sich
gesetzgeberische verantwortung in der
respektierung der freiheit des
sterbewilligen oder haben wir als
gesetzgeber nicht auch eine
verpflichtung zur sorge für alle
beteiligten betroffenen also auch
gegenüber den angehörigen zumindest
zumindest müssen wir den angehörigen die
versicherung das versprechen geben
können dass der ernsthaftigkeit des
sterbewunsch es eines besonders
sorgfältiges augenmerk geschenkt wird
das mit missbrauch besonders sorgfältig
verhindert zu werden versucht und das
aber auch beratung den zugang zu den
individuellen benötigten hilfsangeboten
niederschwellig und tatsächlich auch
erreichbar eröffnet und vielleicht einen
anderen ausweg zu finden als den freitod
wir brauchen beratung und hilfsangebote
für den sterbewilligen aber auch für
sein umfeld seine angehörigen
vielen dank
robert
die debatte ist der kollege friedrich
straetmanns der vorkommen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sie hätte
kolleginnen und kollegen wir diskutieren
das thema suizidhilfe und in der debatte
drückt sich eine ernsthafte
beschäftigung mit diesem thema aus weil
es unsere alle angeht tod und sterben
sind aus dem bewusstsein unserer
gesellschaft verdrängt worden
und anders als beim einen bäuerlichen
vorfahren wird der tote eben nicht mehr
in der deele des bauernhauses aufgebaut
und von den nachbarn zum friedhof
begleitet
die haben uns eine emotionale distanz
zum tode aufgebaut und schlicht gesagt
tod passt in unsere gesellschaft
namenloser effektivität kaum doch hinein
denn was ist am tod eines menschen
effektiv über gasche nun hat uns das
bundesverfassungsgericht mit seiner
entscheidung vom 26.2 2020 aufgetragen
die strafe der sterbehilfe neu zu regeln
und als wohnsitz ist es angesprochen
worden natürlich sind die autonomie des
oder der sterbewilligen zu beachten
aber auch das soziale nöte und zwänge
der betroffenen nicht wirtschaftlich
zusätzlich noch ausgenutzt werden
sollten
ich bin überzeugt ist muss zwar eine
grundsätzliche straffreiheit der hilfe
beim suizid geben dennoch stehe ich auch
dafür ein dass wir weiterhin die
strafbarkeit der täter schaftlichen
aktiven sterbehilfe wie sie im
strafgesetzbuch geregelt ist behalten
aber wir sind durch die
gerichtsentscheidung verpflichtet als
gesetzgeber alternativen anzubieten
wir können uns hier nicht kleinmachen
nicht wegducken damit ist zugleich aber
auch die abgrenzung klar der weg der
selbsttötung darf eben nicht komplett
verstellt sein
aber dieser weg hat sich nach meiner
überzeugung an leid
zu orientieren und die möchte ich ein
bisschen beleuchten
es bedarf zum einen einer breiten
gesellschaftlichen diskussion über
dieses thema es bedarf aber auch eine
enttabuisierung des themas sterben
es bedarf aber auch einer verhinderung
des gefühls einer normalisierung von
selbsttötung und in dem moment wo ich
das aussprechen bin ich mir bewusst dass
wird der schwierigste punkt sein dass es
eben nicht zu einer
selbstverständlichkeit normalität wird
wer das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts auswertet
sieht auch die richterinnen und richter
haben auch gerade erörtert ob soziale
situation von betroffenen die
entscheidung für den tod wesentlich
beeinflussen sie haben versucht die
situation aus vergleichen mit anderen
ländern zu beleuchten sie etwas sehr
schwierig ist die größte frage ist ob
die soziale situation verbunden mit der
eventuellen überzeugung den eigenen
angehörigen mühe und kosten zu sparen
hierzu beiträgt ich denke wir brauchen
und ich komme zum schluss einen massiven
ausbau sämtlicher beratungsangebote
einen massiven ausbau der
palliativmedizin auch das ist ein
wesentlicher punkt und ich plädiere
dafür dass wir in der beratung die hier
notwendig ist insgesamt einen wert
darauf legen eine bejagung zum leben zu
bewirken vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich trete kollegin sylvia kotting-uhl
fraktion oder austausch zu bündnis
90/die wurden
verehrter präsident meine kolleginnen
und kollegen mit 68 jahren bin ich das
älteste mitglied meiner fraktion und ich
stelle mir fragen wie will ich sterben
wie will ich leben
dann will ich nicht mehr leben und wenn
ich nicht mehr leben will
dann steht mein start metern gegenüber
ich stelle mir die hand oder begrenzt er
mich schützt er mich von meinem willen
wir müssen ein neues gesetz machen so
genau diesen fragen
das im bundestag in seiner mehrheit
gemacht ich hatte dem gesetz nicht
zugestimmt
dazu hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
nein gesagt mit eingesetzter beihilfe
zum suizid sind wir haben kern unserer
verfassung der selbstbestimmung der
mensch in seiner unantastbaren würde und
freiheit das klingt großartig
und dann stehen wir vor dem spiegel und
sehen uns das kleine ist also abhängig
ist von allem um es her von zuwendungen
anerkennung sozialen beziehungen
niemand von uns ist nur ein selbst jeder
von uns ist teil von gemeinschaft von
familie freundschaften sozialen
zusammenhängen gesellschaft das ist dass
selbst das kann selbst bestimmt zeit
seien in einer welt die bestimmt wird
von diesen abhängigkeiten von regeln und
normen aber auch unwägbarkeiten wo
bestimmt sich das selbst unbeeinflusst
überfordert uns unser grundgesetz mit
seiner vorstellung des selbstbestimmten
menschen
der freie wille wann ist er frei man
unumstößlich wie sollen wir das wissen
auch wille ist nicht absolut muss also
der staat eine nie als absolut zu
betrachtenden bilden
eines letztlich nicht selbstbestimmt
sein können weil abhängigen menschen
versuchen zu verändern
wenn dieser wille unbegreiflich scheint
ich halte das für ein missverständnis
unser grundgesetz weist das alles es
sieht bei selbstbestimmtheit nicht
menschen die unabhängig von ihrer
umgebung ihre entscheidungen fällen
es sieht menschen in sozialen umfeld
menschen die nach glück streben und die
ängste haben ja auch auf wunsch nach
suizid spielen ängste eine rolle
angst vor leiden für autonomie
verlustangst eine last zu sein
was immer der staat gegen solche ängste
aufbieten kann das muss er tun
aber gefühle wie verlorenheit trauer
angst lebensmüdigkeit zu eliminieren
kann nicht gelingen
sie gehören zu uns menschen wir haben
ein recht auf sie selbst bestimmt heute
erreichen ist wie reif werden ein
prozess unser grundgesetz gibt uns mit
seinen vielfältigen grundrechten mit
seinem freiheits angebot die besten
voraussetzungen für diesen prozess und
das immer wieder individuell daraus
machen passt es nicht dazu
ausgerechnet am ende dieses lebens
langen prozesses die freiheit zu
beschneiden der menschen abzusprechen
am ende seines weges seinen willen nicht
zu kennen unseren einzigartigen
grundgesetz entspricht einer
gesellschaft in der die menschen im
rahmen des gemeinwesens leben dürfen wie
sie wollen und sterben dürfen wenn sie
wollen und deshalb muss die beihilfe zum
suizid geregelt werden aber nicht im
strafrecht da gehört sie nicht hin
[Applaus]
das plädoyer von sylvia kotting-uhl von
bündnis 90 die grünen im deutschen
bundestag auf sie folgt jetzt christian
schmidt aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen
kollegen höchst persönliche
entscheidungen und wege zu
kategorisieren zu objektivieren
das ist ein der gesetzgeberisch
allerhöchste herausforderung der wir uns
nun geradezu wenden müssen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat in den
mittelpunkt seines urteils den freien
willen jedes einzelnen menschen gestellt
komme jetzt eine autonome entscheidung
seine entscheidung zum suizid zu
respektieren
wir fördern muss der staat dies
allerdings nicht unmöglich machen darf
er ihn aber auch nicht auf diese
grundsätzlichen erwägungen muss man aber
auch in einem größeren werte rahmen
denke ich antworten
wir können und dürfen nicht unser
gesetzgeberische aufgabe nur darin sehen
sozusagen ein suizid begleitgesetz dem
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts
nach zu senden
wir haben bei allem respekt vor der
freien entscheidung des einzelnen die
gemeinsame aufgabe ein schützendes
konzept hin zum leben zu schaffen und
diese schwerste aller entscheidungen die
denkbar sind nicht noch gesellschaftlich
zu befördern
davon zu unterscheiden ist die aufgabe
wie der rahmen für nicht
geschäftsmäßigen unterstützung eines
suizids willigen zu setzen ist wir
hatten das ja im 217 im jahre 2015
durchaus im blick gehabt
es gibt also keinen anspruch auf quasi
staatliche unterstützung aber auch keine
erlaubnis zur verunmöglichen solch einer
entscheidung das heißt dass ärzte und
lebenserfahrenen menschen schon auch mit
dem suizidwilligen prüfen dürfen und
müssen ob diese wille ebenso frei
gebildet ist eben gerade bei kollegen
kotting-uhl verstanden und gesehen
wieder wie schwierig diese ambivalenz
der sohn politik von mensch der eben
nicht alleine aus sich heraus lebt und
immer einflüssen ausgesetzt es dass eine
von einem drängenden zwingenden einfluss
andy unterschieden werden kann denen die
dann mit einem so zu kulturellen
mainstream mit einer vorstellung der
test zur last fallen oder anderen einen
unangemessenen druck ausüben
das muss herausgefunden werden es ist
außerordentlich schwer und ich glaube
wir werden hier für besonders viel
energie verwenden müssen wir müssen
allerdings auch uns völlig klar sein
dass ein schutzkonzept eben keine suizid
ermutigende umwelt zu lassen sollte
sozusagen kein wärter syndrom aber auch
kein enkel syndrom entstehen lassen kann
hier sind die interdependenzen
außerordentlich intensiv und groß
gesellschaftliche und wohl ein allgemein
und cola gabriel blutgruppen
insbesondere müssen sozusagen spezial
general präventive und assistierende
konzepte erhalten die prävention ist die
schwester einer gesetzgeberischen
regelung die so wie sie in einem
gewissen rahmen bei freier entscheidung
dann auch ermöglicht
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist der kollege der
doktorand aus der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr gerne präsident werde kollegen wir
haben meiner zeit als assistenzarzt
fragte mich eine todkranke patientin ob
sie eine spritze haben können sie wolle
einfach nicht mehr leben
sie begründete das damit dass sie nicht
mehr zur last fallen möchte nicht den
angehörigen nicht dem pflegepersonal und
besonderes sollte sie keinen mehr in
diesem zustand sehen vor allem ihrer
familie und vor allem ihre enkel nicht
dann habe ich sie gefragt wenn alle
diese gründe nicht bestünden würden sie
dann weiter leben wollen
auch wenn es nur für zwei drei wochen
wäre das sagt es sie eindeutig ja ja zum
leben meine damen und herren die meisten
menschen wünschen nämlich im grunde
keine selbsttötung sondern sie möchten
hilfe sozialen beistand in der
gesellschaft oder eben eine vernünftige
sterbebegleitung zu leben zum beispiel
64 prozent der ärzte eine aktive
sterbehilfe ab der weltärztebund
bekräftigte dies in seiner ablehnung von
sterbehilfe und ärztlich unterstützten
selbstmords
die europäische vereinigung für
palliative medizin sieht ärzte in einem
fundamentalen konflikt rechtlicher und
ethischer werte prinzipien medizinisches
töten gegen den willen des patienten zu
zulassen und meine damen und herren was
das schlimmste ist ist insgesamt
tötungshandlung zu verharmlosen und sie
damit vor allem den gesellschaftsfähig
zu machen damit meine damen
und das wurde heute schon so oft gesagt
ist die büchse der pandora geöffnet
da nützt auch keine
verfassungsrechtliche legitimation und
wenn wir dennoch als politiker gefordert
sind eine rechtliche lösung zu finden
dann müssen diese hürden de facto so
hoch gehängt werden dass eine
selbsttötung fast nicht möglich ist
denn es gilt einfach der ethischen
grundsatz und für ärzte ganz besonders
du sollst nicht töten jemanden
umzubringen ist auch nicht aufgabe eines
arztes sondern die aufgabe ist es das
leben eines jeden menschen möglichst bis
zum letzten atemzug menschenwürdig und
erträglich zu gestalten
ich denke dass bei einer gut ausgebauten
palliativversorgung und psychologischer
betreuung insbesondere junge menschen
der wunsch nach dem tod sehr sehr
schnell nachlässt
gerade wenn wir an die geschichte
deutschlands denken dürfen wir
insbesondere was die sterbehilfe angeht
nicht vorreiter sein
da die bestehende gesetzeslage durchaus
ausreichend ist vielen dank meine damen
und herren
wie soll man am end menschen umgehen die
ein suizid wünschen wie soll man mit der
unterstützung dritter umgehen darüber
diskutiert der bundestag in einer
vereinbart und debatte edgar franke wird
als nächstes sprechen für die spd
fraktion denn meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren wir als politik sollten
urteile der höchsten gerichte
respektieren so hat das
bundesverwaltungsgericht das wäre was
angesprochen worden 20 17 entschieden
dass bestimmte sterbewillige eine
die tal wirkendes medikament oder mittel
erhalten können darauf warten die
berechtigten wenn sie überhaupt noch
leben aber bis heute vergebens das ist
aus meiner sicht absolut nicht in
ordnung ist auch nicht er soll nicht in
ordnung meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren das ranghoher vertreter politik
einer rede gleich nach mir und auch die
ärzteschaft sich über dieses urteil ganz
klar hinweggesetzt habe und das auch bei
uns im gesundheitsausschuss so deutlich
kommuniziert haben auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat im
vergangenen jahr wie wir alle wissen ein
urteil mit klaren tenor gefällt wer
sterben will darf sich dabei
unterstützen lassen
das ergibt sich so das
bundesverfassungsgericht aus dem
allgemeinen persönlichkeitsrecht auch
diese entscheidung sollten wir ja müssen
wir respektieren und müssen wir aus
politik auch umsetzen
dafür schaffen wir oder wollen wir aber
müssen wir einen verbindlichen rahmen
schaffen der sterbehilfe ermöglicht ein
rahmen der die würde des einzelnen der
die autonomie des einzelnen auch
respektiert und sichert ein rahmen der
aber auch das sage ich ganz klar
verhindert dass menschen in den suizid
getrieben werden menschen müssen beraten
werden menschen müssen auch zum leben
beraten werden der gesetzentwurf den
genau die kühler sind katja keul und
andere vorgeschlagen haben setzt
zumindest den richtigen rahmen und es
auch eine gute diskussionsgrundlage für
den weiteren für die weiteren debatten
ich würde drei gründe nehmen oder nennen
besser gesagt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen warum der entwurf vernünftig
und sachgerecht ist erstens der entwurf
setzt das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zulässig um
für alle die nicht mehr leben wollen aus
welchem grund auch immer schafft er
einen klaren weg
sie können mit der unterstützung anderer
selbstbestimmte sterben deswegen bin ich
zuversichtlich dass dieser entwurf auch
rechtssicher ist zweiter
der entwurf steht auch im einklang
selbst mit christlichen humanistischen
werten er nimmt die menschen gerade in
ihrem sterbewunsch ernst und zeigt ihnen
dass die gesellschaft in schwierigen
zeiten sie nicht allein lässt sie berät
und ihnen hilft das ist auch eine form
von gelebter solidarität und auch
respekt und auch gelebte nächstenliebe
drittens der vorschlag stellt auch das
leben in den mittelpunkt denn die
sterbewilligen bekommen alle wege
aufgezeigt die dafür sprechen
weiterzuleben
ihm wird auch deutlich gemacht uns als
gesellschaft liegt viel an dir wie viel
darin dass der jeweilige weiterlebt
ihnen werden auch perspektiven für das
leben auf gezeigt auch so kann man
vielleicht sogar leben retten indem man
mehrere möglichkeiten ergebnisoffen
aufzeigt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir müssen jetzt einen würdigen und
sicheren rahmen für die sterbehilfe in
deutschland schaffen also ein gesetz das
nicht nur respekt vor der entscheidung
des bundesverfassungsgerichtes zeigt
sondern respekt auch vor den menschen
die ihnen einen besonderen
außergewöhnlichen notlage eine autonome
entscheidung treffen wollten ich danke
auch ihren sparen wird hier in der
debatte sprechen aber auch er wird als
abgeordneter reden kommt also aus den
reihen seiner fraktion der
unionsfraktion und spricht hier eben
nicht in seiner rolle als
bundesgesundheitsminister obwohl das
natürlich in seinen bereich auffällt
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir sprechen in dieser debatte auch über
großes leid das menschen widerfährt es
geht um menschen deren schmerzen deren
leiden deren leiden vielleicht auch an
der welt so groß ist dass sie sterben
wollen eine für die meisten eigentlich
unvorstellbare vorstellung und doch auch
ausdruck von freiheit und freien will in
manchen fällen und es geht gleichzeitig
um die fürsorgepflichten des staates der
gesellschaft und unsere werteordnung ein
ethisches dilemma in vielerlei hinsicht
jeder der sich mit den schicksalen
dahinter beschäftigt mit den betroffenen
und ihren angehörigen spricht weiß dass
ich muss sagen dass sich erst mal schwer
schlucken musste als ich von dem urteil
des bundesverfassungsgerichts im
vergangenen jahr hörte karlsruhe hat das
uneingeschränkte verbot der beihilfe zum
suizid für verfassungswidrig erklärt und
gleichzeitig ein umfassendes recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben erkannt in
jeder phase menschliche existenz so
heißt es im urteil
dies gilt es zu berücksichtigen wenn wir
nun darüber debattieren ob und wie
sterbehilfe in deutschland künftig
geregelt
allein das wort schon geregelt sein soll
sterben
das bundesministerium für gesundheit hat
diesen auftrag auch für sich angenommen
und als beitrag für die
gesellschaftliche debatte ein
arbeitsentwurf und ich sage ausdrücklich
einen arbeitsentwurf zur verfügung
gestellt das darin vorgeschlagenen
abgestufte schutzkonzept basiert auf
zwei säulen erstens die hilfe zur
selbsttötung sollte mit einem neuen
straftatbestand im paragraph 217 unter
strafe stehen die hürden zur
assistierenden selbsttötung sehr sehr
hoch bleibt
für mich ist klar es darf unter keinen
umständen einen sanften druck geben
gesellschaftlich oder auch im privaten
umfeld angebote der still sterbehilfe
auch annehmen zu wollen das was sie auch
herr kollege als modell
das da entstehen kann beschrieben haben
eine solche entwicklung wäre für unsere
gesellschaft verteilt sollte zweitens
vielmehr einen regulatorischen rahmen
wenn denn schon mit klar definierten
ausnahmen geben der ärztinnen und ärzte
eindeutig vor strafverfolgung schützt
wenn sie sterbehilfe leisten
zu diesem rahmen zellen aus unserer
sicht unter anderem eine ergebnisoffene
ärztliche aufklärung die einbeziehung
von gemeinnützigen
beratungsorganisationen notwendige
wartefristen zwischen entscheidungen und
umsetzung ein ganz klares werbeverbot
was aus meiner sicht übrigens klar auch
nicht dazugehört und das will ich hier
sagen weil es auch angesprochen worden
ist von einigen kolleginnen und kollegen
was aus meiner sicht nicht dazugehört
ist eine verpflichtung des staates
selbst medikamente zur selbsttötung zur
verfügung zu stellen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat sehr
klar gemacht das ist zwar ein
umfassendes recht auf selbstbestimmtes
sterben gebe aber eben keinen anspruch
darauf dass dabei geholfen wird
der staat sollte nicht kein beamter
einer behörde und erst recht nicht ein
minister nach seiner politischen laune
darüber entscheiden ob jemand sterben
darf oder nicht und nach welchen
kriterien diese medikamente zur
verfügung gestellt werden das sollte
nicht der staat entscheiden
nein und im übrigen wenn wir schon bei
der juristerei sind ein
bundesverwaltungsgerichts urteil im
einzelfall ist was anderes als ein
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil und
verwaltungsgerichte entscheiden
mittlerweile so in dem sinne wie wir
entschieden haben nach der entscheidung
des verfassungsgerichtes auch das bitte
ich in der debatte hilfe suchen
rücksicht und herr präsident ich weiß
ich bin über derzeit aber weil das von
kolleginnen und kollegen angesprochen
worden das wollte ich noch erwähnen der
staat jedenfalls sollte es nicht
entscheidende sollte eine individuelle
entscheidung von arzt und patient in
einem besonderen vertrauensverhältnis
sein das jahr geregelt sein muss und das
ist eine debatte nicht mit schwarz und
weiß eine debatte die sich führen
dankeschön
vielen dank herr kollege sparen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin glock
tartaglia der reeder aus der spd
fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen tod und sterben
sind in unserer gesellschaft nach wie
vor stark tabuisiert und allzu oft
verdrängen wir die grenzen des lebens
und auch deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
hier heute diese debatte führen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat in
seinem urteil klar gestellt dass das
allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht als
ausdruck persönlicher autonomie auch das
recht auf selbstbestimmtes sterben
umfasst es ist also eine höchst
individuelle entscheidung dem eigenen
leben der eigenen existenz ein ende zu
setzen
die bewertung von lebensqualität und
sinnhaftigkeit sind dabei die maßstäbe
uns hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
aufgetragen klare kriterien für den
zugang zu hilfsmitteln zu definieren die
zur umsetzung dieses suizid wunsches
notwendig sind wichtig ist mir dabei und
da weiß ich mich in guter gesellschaft
mit katja keul renate künast und edgar
franke dass insbesondere schwer
erkrankte ein recht auf würde vollen
suizid haben aber auch denjenigen die
aus anderen gründen nämlich etwa in
aller allerschwersten lebenskrisen ihrem
leben ein ende setzen wollen dürfen wir
ein recht auf suizid nicht verwehren
davon bin ich zutiefst überzeugt sich
etwa mit niereninsuffizienz verhungern
und verdursten zu lassen
schwermütig und des lebens überdrüssig
sich verzweifelt vor den zug zu werfen
oder sich im wald zu erhängen all das
halte ich nicht für würdevolle suizide
es passiert aber tagtäglich suizidale
benötigen in aller erster linie beratung
und information im kampf gegen ihre
verzweiflung und dennoch kann es auch
danach
so sein dass der wunsch nach
selbsttötung fortbesteht
in allen fällen aber kommt ärztinnen und
ärzten eine besondere verantwortung zu
wenn sie sich nach intensiven gesprächen
und beratungen vom freien willen zum
suizid bei ihren patientinnen und
patienten überzeugen sollen
dies nähmen nicht ist eine conditio sine
qua non für die abgabe von todbringenden
mitteln
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ganz
gleich wie wir im weiteren
gesetzesverfahren debattieren und um
lösungen ringen werden keine der
entscheidungen darf ärztinnen und ärzte
oder pflegekräfte kriminalisieren oder
begleitende angehörige culpa bieli
sieren uns aber bleibt die verantwortung
hilfen und beratung deutlich auszubauen
und ganz besonders gilt dies für hospiz
und palliativmedizin
vielen dank sagte reeder nächster redner
ist rudolf henke er ist arzt und war
auch über zehn jahre von 2007 bis 2009
10 der vorsitzende der ärztegewerkschaft
marburger bund
[Applaus]
präsident verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren
ja es war das bundesverfassungsgericht
hat das verbot geschäftsmäßiger sowie
zieht beihilfe aufgehoben und daran
können wir nicht vorbei und zugleich hat
das bundesverfassungsgericht deutlich
gemacht dass der gesetzgeber und die
gesellschaft legitimiert bleiben einer
entwicklung entgegenzutreten an deren
ende sich der assistierte rietz als
normale form der lebens beendigung
insbesondere für alte und kranke
menschen etablieren können
die geeignet sei autonomie gefährdende
soziale pressionen zu erhalten so das
urteil vom 26 02 20 randnummer 248 liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren in deutschland sterben jedes jahr
etwa 10.000 menschen den suizid tod und
die schätzungen gehen davon aus dass die
zahl der suizidversuche etwa beim 10 bis
30 fachen liegt von denen die einen
suizidversuch überleben müssen wir das
ca 90 prozent keinen zweiten versuch
unternehmen
und deswegen glaube ich steht ganz im
vordergrund unserer aufgabe die
suizidprävention so zu organisieren dass
die rahmenbedingungen die wir vorfinden
nicht dazu ermuntern dass die zahl
suizide steigt unsere erste aufgabe ist
die suizidprävention und dabei liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen gehört mit dazu
sich mit dem auseinanderzusetzen was
suizidalität bedeutet und suizidalität
ist kein individuell über die zeit
beständiges phänomen der in der
psychiatrie bekannte zustand der
kognitiven einengung akut gefährdete
personen kann über wochen hinweg den
eindruck einer eindeutigen
entschlossenheit hervorrufen und
suizidalität ist dennoch ein phänomen
welches sich in menschlichen beziehungen
entwickelt sich in beziehung ereignet
und durch erfahrungen in beziehungen
auch verändert sie ist kein beständiger
psychischer zustand vielmehr befinden
sich suizidale menschen meist in einem
zustand der ambivalenz und auch die
einschränkungen der medialen verbreitung
von suizid methoden und anleitung hat
nachweis nicht suizid präventive effekte
und deswegen finde ich muss zunächst
einmal die frage der wirksamsten suizid
prävention in den vordergrund und dazu
gehört auch eine gehörig lange zeit um
diese fehlende konstanz des willens und
die dynamik der entwicklung der sozietät
in begegnungen in beziehungen und in
menschliche miteinander sich entwickeln
zu lassen bin sicher dass das noch
etlicher debatten bedarf ich danke ihnen
für die aufmerksamkeit
bilder gefällige
[Musik]
als nächsten redner rufe ich auf den
kollegen sven schulz aus der spd
fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir stehen vor der aufgabe das
vom bundesverfassungsgericht
geschriebene freiheitsrecht auf suizid
zu gewährleisten und gleichzeitig
wildwuchs und missbrauch zu verhindern
es geht darum hilfe zum leben zu leisten
aber wenn es die betreffenden denn
wirklich selbst wollen auch hilfe zum
suizid zu ermöglichen
ich möchte hier darstellen warum bei
diesem abwägen das strafrecht meiner
meinung nach ein ungeeignetes instrument
ist und zwar anhand eines erlebnisses
ist in meinem privaten umfeld eine mir
gut bekannte frau erhielt eine schlimme
diagnose hls sie beschloss ihrem leben
ein baldiges ende zu setzen unter den
bedingungen des alten strafrechts vaters
schwierig aber sie hat über umwege
trotzdem etwas organisiert und ja man
hat dann beim suizid assistiert alles
gut also ich denke nicht die frau musste
sich illegal medikamente besorgen und
alles still und heimlich machen ohne
professionelle hilfe und ihr mann der
gerade seine frau in den tod begleitet
hatte wurde direkt nach dem suizid zur
polizei gebracht und verhört anstatt mit
seiner familie trauern zu dürfen dieses
beispiel hat mir gezeigt es ist ein weg
nötig der den menschen den
selbstbestimmten würdigen abschied
ermöglicht sicher schmerzlos begleitet
auch von herzen und mit angehörigen die
dann nicht die polizei fürchten müssen
der
and loathing klar sitte lauterbach und
anderen den ich unterstütze schlägt
einen solchen weg vor und setzt dabei
auf hilfe und gute beratung anstatt auf
die strafandrohung
mir ist dabei aber wichtig zu betonen
dass die beratung auch wege ohne suizid
aufzeigen muss und dass wir mehr
palliativmedizinische angebote im hospiz
plätze schaffen müssen auch
psychologische hilfe in verzweifelten
lebenslagen es geht hier nicht darum die
menschen schnell in den tod zu befördern
sondern es geht darum ihnen zu helfen
und dann wenn sie es wirklich wollen
auch beim suizid kollegen kollegen
dieses thema hat auch noch eine andere
dimension bisher ist es ja so dass
diejenigen mit kenntnissen mit kontakten
mit geld schon wege finden die fahren
halt mal grob gesagt zur not in die
schweiz
diejenigen ohne solche möglichkeiten
stehen da können ihr recht auf suizid
nicht gut wahrnehmen leiden weiter oder
verfallen auf unsichere schmerzhafte
suizid methoden es ist hilfe für alle
menschen nötig unabhängig von geld und
status
ich freue mich auf die weiteren
beratungen hoffe dass wir zu einer
schnellen gesetzgebung kommen denn die
bürgerinnen und bürger erwarten zu recht
unterstützung regeln für die suizid
assistenz und einen sicheren rechtlichen
rahmen herzlichen danke
[Applaus]
nächster redner in der debatte ist peter
weiß erst für die unions fraktion
sprecher für arbeit und soziales
[Applaus]
präsident verehrte kolleginnen kollegen
ja es gibt ihn den autonomen
selbstbestimmten freihandel den menschen
der sich im zweifel entscheidet ich will
den freitod
aber wenn wir in einer solchen
parlamentsdebatte orient uhren suchen
was und wie sollen wir als
parlamentarier gesetz das regeln
dann beschäftigt mich zuallererst einmal
die tatsache dass über 90 prozent derer
die eine suizid handlung vorgenommen
haben menschen sind diana psychischen
erkrankung leiden in der regel einer
depression und alle erfahrungen aus der
arbeit mit solchen menschen zeigt dass
sehr wohl diesen mitbürgerin mitbürgern
mit passgenauen zielgruppenspezifischen
und niedrigschwelligen suizid
präventionsangeboten sehr wirksam
geholfen werden könnte
wer sich selbst das leben nehmen will
befinden sich meist in einer absolut
ausnahmesituationen oder einer situation
von schrecklicher verzweiflung und große
erlebnis angst und deshalb trifft nur
eine sehr geringe zahl an die wirklich
dauerhaft fünf geschafft frei getroffene
entscheidungen und aus meiner eigenen
erfahrung die jetzt mit den in den
letzten jahren aus meiner familie
verstorbenen kenne ist dass in den
gesprächen am lebensende sehr oft
todeswunsch und lebenswunsch sehr nahe
beieinander liegen oft im gleichen
gespräch 3 2 setzte auseinander
was folgt jetzt da raus
ich glaube wenn wir etwas recht regeln
wollen als parlament dann sollten wir
als allererstes darauf wert legen dass
er ein umfassendes legislative
schutzkonzept schafften zudem folgende
maßnahmen gehören müssen einfach lästig
und flächendeckender ausbau von hospiz
palliativen angeboten mit sowohl
medizinische pflege schau also auch
psychosoziale und seelsorgerliche
begleitung der ausbau von suizid
präventiven angeboten
der ausbau von angeboten gegen
einsamkeit und isolation eine frei
verantwortliche entscheidung treffen
wenn alle möglichen alternativen und
alle möglichkeiten die das leben bietet
bekannt offen und auch zugänglich sind
freier wille ist da wirklich frei
ausreichender und umfassender
informationen und ich finde dass das zu
gewährleisten ist zuallererst unsere
verpflichtung und aufgabe als politiker
und gesetzgeber
ich glaube dass wenn wir gerade das
schaffen dass wir dann verhindern dass
unsere gesellschaft möglicherweise auf
eine schiefe bahn gerät weil wir dem
lebensschutz gerade auch davon wohl
raten gruppen nicht mehr den gebührenden
rang einräumen
das sollten wir uns allerdings zur
förderten aufgabe der politik machen
vielen dank soweit peter weiß für die
unionsfraktion und für die spd-fraktion
spricht jetzt claudia moll sie sind es
im gesundheitsausschuss ist von beruf
altenpflegerin
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich bin sehr dankbar dass wir heute
diese offene orientierungs debatte zur
suizidhilfe führen
ich selbst bin noch auf der suche nach
der richtigen lösung
viele jahre habe ich als altenpflegerin
und als fachkraft für gerontopsychiatrie
gearbeitet
dabei habe ich viele schöne rührende
situation mit meinen mir anvertrauten
menschen erleben dürfen aber auch viele
traurige ereignisse für mich ist und war
es immer selbstverständlich den letzten
weg gemeinsam zu gehen und dabei habe
ich bei schwerstkranken aus therapierten
menschen die angst die schmerzen und die
verzweiflung hautnah miterlebt das
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts
eröffnet uns eine möglichkeit zur
suizidhilfe die nicht nur alten und
schwerstkranken menschen helfen sondern
auch für menschen in jeglichem vor
sparen krisensituation hilfe anbieten
kann
ebenfalls bei menschen mit schwersten
psychischen erkrankungen
meines erachtens gibt es dort keine
begrenzung
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir uns
intensiv mit der suizidprävention
auseinandersetzen werte kolleginnen und
kollegen sie glauben nicht wie oft ich
den satz gehört habe ach wär ich doch
schon tot
oft verblasst dieser wunsch wenn die
menschen gut umsorgt begleitet und
palliativ gut versorgt werden
vor diesem hintergrund möchte ich
dringend appellieren dass wir uns darum
kümmern
diese immer noch bestehenden defizite in
den krankenhäusern und
pflegeeinrichtungen zu beseitigen und
den weiteren wichtigen bedarf und ausbau
voran zu bringen
denn hospiz und palliativ bedeutenden
sich schon ein wichtiger teil der
suizidprävention suizidhilfe muss das
bleiben was sie bislang gewesen ist eine
ausnahme in extremsituation schwersten
leidens ich möchte keine regelung die
die suizidhilfe zu einer neuen
normalität des sterns macht am meisten
haben die menschen angst dass ihr leben
an technischen geräten hängend endet nur
man muss am lebensende nicht alles über
sich ergehen lassen
und da besteht ein riesiges
informationsdefizit therapie abbruch und
therapie verzicht gehören auch zu einer
guten palliativversorgung wir werden
auch nicht darüber nachdenken müssen wie
die einrichtungen selbst mit diesen
fragen umgehen werden
ich möchte ein kleiner einrichtung
arbeiten wo suizidhilfe bestattet ist
ich möchte keine suizidhilfe leisten
möchten sie das ich verurteile kohl
keinen suizid glauben sie mir
auch das habe ich schon ganz oft erlebt
und es ist furchtbar ich möchte nicht
dass daraus ein dienstleistungs system
wird vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau kollegin monica ali
claudi haben mal folgt jetzt schwierig
elstorfer für die unionsfraktion auch er
sitzt im gesundheitsausschuss
[Applaus]
herr präsident sowie die kolleginnen und
kollegen die suizid forschung zeigt dass
die überwiegende zahl der suizidversuche
auf psychischer und sozialer not
basieren
die versuche sind in den meisten fällen
verzweiflungs reaktionen auf ein
schwerwiegendes ereignis oder eine
soziale notsituation der bund früher aus
dem leben zu scheiden ist deshalb ganz
oft ein ambivalentes beziehungsweise
kurzfristiges phänomen was häufig
abklingt wenn man es nicht befeuert in
einem land welches gerade alles dafür
tut um einzelne menschenleben zu retten
darf es hier flankierend ein geschäft
mit dem tod geben war nicht unser
grundsatz immer dass wir die hand
reichen zur hilfe um dich zur tötung
menschen sollten auf ihrem letzten
irdischen weg palliativmedizinische oder
durch die hospizbewegung begleitet
werden um ihnen leid schmerzen angst und
solche dinge zu nehmen um nicht von
entsprechenden angeboten irgendwie um
schwert zu werden um erleben abzukürzen
durch gesetzliche regelungen welche den
assistierten tod erlauben und
ermöglichen wird natürlich auch im
grundsatz und erlauben sie mir diese
persönliche meinung aus dem christlichen
bereich auch komplett weggewischt
kardinal höffner sagte 1987 der mensch
der nicht an einer krankheit oder an
einem leiden sondern dann wenn gott ein
leben vollendet hat wir dürfen gerade in
dieser schwierigen zeit
welche natürlich auch von schmerzen
entbehrung geprägt ist
den schwächeren in unserer gesellschaft
nicht einfach die tür der lebens
abkürzung aufstoßen
es ist vielmehr ein zeichen der achtung
das wegen sowohl gesellschaftlich als
auch medizinischen persönliche
aufmerksamkeit schenken um kuba sowie
leiden ernst nehmen und so verstehe ich
auch diese debatte und ich danke ihnen
allen für ihre eindrücke und für ihre
meinungen weil das ist wichtig und was
kann auch zur lösung beitragen gerichte
entscheiden
berichte über gewalt und ich glaube dass
wir gestern bei unserem vorgespräch und
das hat mich beeindruckt dass professor
beine lehrstuhlinhaber für sicher zu
ihrer therapie der universität
witten/herdecke gesagt habe dass vor
allem auch andere maßnahmen wie
änderungen zb beim brückenbau bei
autobahnbrücken oder auch bei führungen
von eisenbahn dienen dass das auch mit
eine rolle spielt hier
diese ganzen suizid ihren aktivitäten zu
beschenken vorsorgemaßnahmen verbesserte
aufklärung sowie gewachsene sensibilität
in der berichterstattung und auch
verkleinerungen der
medikamentenverpackungen spielen keine
rolle
daran wollen wir weiter arbeiten uns
leitet leben stärken je nach situation
und suizidprävention fördern
ich glaube das ist der richtig herzlich
[Applaus]
die klu wir auf den nächsten redner
alexander groß cdu csu fraktion
alexander kraus sitzt auch im ausschuss
für gesundheit
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren die frage nach dem
assistierten suizid ist die frage was
das leben bedeutet
als christ sehe ich das leben als
bedingungslos wertvoll an von anfang bis
zum ende
das leben ist für mich ein geschenk
gottes und dafür und deshalb für uns
menschen nicht verfügbar und das sterben
gehört zum leben dazu
sterben ist ein wichtiger abschnitt im
leben wo man vor dem inneren geistigen
auge sein leben nochmal revue passieren
lässt
wo man darüber nachdenkt was war mir
wichtig gewesen im leben wo man darüber
nachdenkt was kommt nach dem tod und wo
man vielleicht auch darüber nachdenkt
was martin luther sich gefragt hat wie
bekomme ich einen gnädigen gott jetzt
gibt es situationen wo ein mensch sein
leben als wertlos betrachtet und dann
selbstmord denkt wenn es aber eine
hilfestellung für den selbstmord gibt
dann betrachtet nicht nur der betroffene
sein leben in diesem moment als wertlos
sondern dann tut es eine ganze
gesellschaft
das signal das von dieser beihilfe
ausgeht ist doch klar wir als
gesellschaft wir brauchen dich nicht du
bist wertlos
nun spricht das bundesverfassungsgericht
davon dass der assistierte suizid nicht
zur gesellschaftlichen normalität werden
dürfe ich glaube aber genau dieser
effekt wird eintreten wenn man es
ermöglicht das zeigen ja die beispiele
in den niederlanden oder unter schweiz
meine befürchtung ist dass der druck auf
alte und kranke menschen wachsen wird
mit der unausgesprochene botschaft du
hast noch die möglichkeit zum sterben
dann fällst du uns eigentlich noch zu
lasst es gab noch nie so viele
möglichkeiten schmerzen wirksam zu
behandeln wir heute diese möglichkeiten
sollten wir ausschöpfen wir sollten
sterbenden zur seite stehen
wir brauchen keine hilfe zum sterben
sondern wir brauchen eine hilfe beim
sterben
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
mein vater warten seinem lebensende
schwer pflegebedürftig und wurde zu
hause von meiner mutter gerne
aufopferungsvoll und liebevoll gepflegt
wie das viele tausende pflegende
angehörige auch heute tun
bei mir hat sich einsatz eingebrannt von
einem arzt der zum hausbesuch gewesen
ist er hat mein vater gefragt sehen sie
nicht was sie ihrer frau antun
mein vater konnte sich in dem moment
konnte sich zu diesem zeitpunkt
überhaupt nicht mehr bewegen und der
konnte auch schon lange nicht mehr
sprechen
ich möchte nicht dass ein alter oder
kranker mensch bei uns im land diese
frage gestellt bekommt
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
alexander kraus war das hat hier sehr
persönlich vor dem möglichen druck
gewarnt der auf kranken menschen lasten
könnte auf ihn folgt der theorie bett
hirte für die unionsfraktion sind liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der heutige tag
zeigt doch in einer gewissen dramatik
die konfliktsituation zwischen lebens
und gesundheitsschutz auf der einen
seite und freiheitsrechten auf der
anderen seite heute morgen haben wir bei
der diskussion um die reform des
infektionsschutzgesetzes frage gestanden
leben und gesundheit zu schützen und
abzuwägen gegen freiheit und jetzt für
dieselbe diskussion am ende des lebens
mit dem blick auf die entscheidungsmacht
die entscheidungsfreiheit die rechte des
einzelnen für mich ist dabei die
priorisierung immer klar gewesen ohne
lebens und gesundheitsschutz gibt es
keine basis für die freiheit dieser
entscheidungslage der deutsche bundestag
in einem mit großer mehrheit
verabschiedete gesetz gefolgt es waren
fast zwei drittel der abgeordneten die
dem gesetz zugestimmt haben und wir
haben die geschäftsmäßige beihilfe zum
suizid unter strafe stellt das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat ebenso
deutlich nämlich einstimmig dieses
gesetz aufgehoben und sogar noch
weitergehend uns einen regelungs auftrag
für die für die schaffung des rahmens
für das recht auf selbstbestimmte
freitod gegeben
das urteil habe durchaus zu irritationen
geführt
denn es gab kaum ein gesetz das so
intensiv vorbereitet
und am ende abgewogen wurde wie das vom
bundesverfassungsgericht am ende
einstimmig aufgehobene gesetz über
dessen neufassung wir jetzt hier beraten
müssen
ich tue mich schwer diesem auftrag des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zu folgen eine
regelung für das sterben zu finden
ich tue mir schwer als demokrat hier in
der legislative einem auftrag der
judikative folgen zu müssen
und ich tue mich schwer vor meinem
gewissen diese entscheidung diesem
auftrag von bilanzen zu müssen
wenn man das weiterdenkt öffnet sich
fragen öffnet sich der raum für fragen
über fragen
vor allen dingen für die abwägung die
aufgabe der lösung unzähliger
diskriminierungen die notwendigkeit
unterschiedliche lebenssituationen zu
würdigen wie ist es mit dem jungen
mensch der wegen seiner des
liebeskummers sterben will
und wie ist es mit dem alten mensch der
irreversible krank ist
das sind entscheidungen die ich von
meinem gewissen so nicht einfach
verantworten kann
deshalb halte ich den ansatz für richtig
den ansgar heveling vorgetragen hat mit
einer strafrechtlichen regelungen
weiterzumachen sicher abgeschwächt aber
vielleicht beschränkt auf die werbung
denn eines ist klar die selbstbestimmung
die das bundesverfassungsgericht betont
hat adressiert eine irreversibler
entscheidung und die beurteilung erfolgt
nicht durch den der wirklich die
entscheidung trifft sondern durch dritte
und das ist die eigentliche
schwierigkeit
vielen dank
die ausführungen von heribert hirte der
vorletzte redner in dieser debatte zur
suizidhilfe ist axel müller er sitzt
ebenfalls im gesundheitsausschuss wie
schon viele redner und rednerinnen hier
vor ihm mitglied der cdu csu fraktion
ist er auch sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
bundesverfassungsgerichts als auslöser
der heutigen debatte hat paragraf 217
stgb für mich nicht erklärt weiter das
recht auf selbstbestimmtes sterben als
ausdruck der persönlichen autonomie und
die möglichkeiten dafür bei dritten
hilfe zu suchen und in anspruch zu
nehmen
zu sehr einschränke es gilt gegenwärtig
der rechtszustand der zum kern der
juristenausbildung gehört beihilfe zum
selbstmord ist nicht strafbar
tötung auf verlangen aber sehr wohl und
dennoch können wir uns damit nicht
zufriedengeben wir spüren alle das
bedürfnis nach ergänzenden regelungen
allen initiativen die heute vorliegen
soll ich wirklich größten respekt sie
sind geprägt von einem
verantwortungsvollen ringen um eine gute
lösung beweisen gestaltungswillen und
haben juristische qualität
ich will ein paar allgemeine gedanken in
die diskussion einbringen die mich ganz
persönlich aber auch viele menschen mit
denen ich in gesprächen war oder in
diskussionen mich befand gesagt und mir
mitgeteilt haben und von denen ich mir
wünschen würde sie würden bei der
weiteren debatte auch berücksichtigung
finden
auffallend ist bei einzelinitiativen das
sich scheinbar die überzeugung
durchgesetzt hat der staat müsse
strukturen schaffen oder zumindest
unterstützen die es dem selbsttötung
willigen ermöglichen seinen willen in
die tat umzusetzen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
allerdings nur untersagt die umsetzung
des autonomen gefassten willens zur
selbsttötung zu unterbinden
eine verpflichtung ein verfahren zu
entwickeln das diese möglichkeit bis ins
kleinste detail regelt die diesen ersten
prozess eines menschen auf normen
basierten regeln weiter ausgestalten hat
es nicht explizit ausgesprochen
hier scheint jedoch zurückhaltung
angesagt und zu den höchsten aufgaben
eines staates gehört es das leben seiner
bürger und bürgerinnen zu schützen
das geht hinein bis in den privaten
bereich wo wir verfahren haben in denen
das staatliche wetteramt wie beim
schwangerschaftsabbruch beispielsweise
greift
kritisch sehe ich daher dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht in seiner
entscheidung die menschenwürde mit der
persönlichen autonomie des individuums
auf eine stufe gestellt hat und dabei
den menschen als sozial verfasstes wesen
aus meiner sicht etwas aus dem blick
verloren hat hier sollte der horizont
des gesetzgebers also der unsrige etwas
weitergehen
für mich trägt sich das nicht mit dem
biblischen grundsatz im inbegriff
menschlicher solidarität einer trage des
anderen last und initiativen beziehen
auch die berufsgruppe der ärzte mit ein
die sich eher bis lagen zurückhaltend zu
assistierten suizid hilfe geäußert haben
deren aufgabe es ist kranke zu heilen
oder deren leiden zu lindern
hier sehe ich auch noch
diskussionsbedarf mit dieser
berufsgruppe und ich möchte noch einmal
zurückkommen auf den einleitenden satz
unseres grundgesetzes im bewusstsein
seiner verantwortung vor gott und den
menschen sind die einleitenden worte des
grundgesetzes nach meinem christlichen
verständnis ist leben ein geschenk
gottes dass man weder ablehnen noch
zurückgeben kann
sterben ist ein teil des lebens daher
muss es klare restriktionen geben und
ich wünsche uns weiterhin eine von solch
hohem respekt geprägte debatte wie sie
heute erleben durfte vielen dank an
und damit kommen wir zum letzten
reservate das ist philipp am tor für die
unionsfraktion kollege philipp amthor
cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen als der deutsche bundestag vor
sechs jahren das verbot der
geschäftsmäßigen förderung der
selbsttötung beschlossen hat habe ich
die damaligen intensiven debatten damals
noch als jurastudent aber mit großer
begeisterung verfolgt ich empfand es als
sternstunden des parlaments intensiv
ernsthaft sensibel abgewogen und dann
ende ausgewählt um so entrüstet da war
ich dann aber als ich mich intensiver
mit der aufheben entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts aus dem
zurückliegenden jahr auseinander gesetzt
habe ich empfangs und ich empfinde es
als übergriffig dass karlsruhe uns als
gesetzgeber so stark beschnitten hat
dass selbst der damals weit gehen sste
entwurf zu einer liberalisierung dass
selbst dieser entwurf wahrscheinlich
verfassungswidrig gewesen wäre
während der gesetzgeber der letzten
legislaturperiode
während viele kollegen die sich heute
auch in der debatte geäußert haben die
tätigkeit von sterbehilfe verein aus wie
ich finde nachvollziehbaren gründen er
in der dimension der autonomie
gefährdung gesehen haben hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht dieses bild in
das gegenteil verkehrt und sterbehilfe
vereine quasi zu autonomie wahren erhöht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen diese
metamorphose
diese umkehr des willens des
gesetzgebers und dieses autonomie
verständnis geht mir zu weit
das bundesverfassungsgericht ist der
letzte interpret aber eben nicht der
allein inter
geht unserer verfassung das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat eine
wächterfunktion aber nicht die primäre
gestaltungs funktion die haben wir als
parlament und deswegen möchte ich zum
ende dieser orientierungs debatte dafür
plädieren dass wir mehr als eine
schreibstube des
bundesverfassungsgerichts in diesem
verfahren sind liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
es geht darum das haben viele vorredner
gesagt dass wir in der frage der
maßstäbe deutlich machen dass das
grundgesetz für uns nicht eine
verfassung des sterbens sondern
zuallererst eine verfassung für das
leben ist das grundgesetz verlangt dass
sich der staat schützend für das leben
einsetzt und das grundgesetz sieht
menschenwürde und schutz des lebens als
und eilten und dabei ist klar
und das muss uns leiten dass die
menschenwürde immer auch rund und grenze
der selbstbestimmung ist die
menschenwürde kulminiert am ende eben
nicht in selbstbestimmung sondern jedes
verständnis von selbstbestimmung über
das wir reden müssen muss sich aus der
menschenwürde ableiten können liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und deshalb ist
eine entscheidung zur suizidprävention
eine entscheidung zur beschränkung der
suizidhilfe kein widerspruch zur
selbstbestimmung sondern einen beitrag
zum schutz der menschenwürde und dafür
müssen wir werben vier klare punkte ich
warne vor einem suizid unterstützungs
gesetz sondern werbe für einen
menschenwürde schutzgesetz wir brauchen
ein klares schutzkonzept wir sollten
eine regelung im strafrecht reffen und
wir müssen für eine wahrung der
kirchlichen autonomie und für einen
tendenz schutz der
religionsgemeinschaften werben tun wir
das selbstbewusst in einem klaren und
auch definierenden
verfassungsverständnis von
selbstbestimmung und menschen der
herzlichen dank
ich schließe eine wie ich finde sehr
interessante tiefgehende und auch
nachdenkliche debatte herzlichen dank an
rät man dafür